hi my name is bert kreischer with
everything going on in the world of
comedy what with violence and jokes i
just want to make sure everyone knows
that at my show at the greek in los
angeles on may 5th there will be no
jokes made about anyone's family other
than my own wait a minute i got a great
joke about your wife being a [ __ ]
well let me hear it hold on she's not
done
mark norman will also be performing with
me may 5th at the greek
you got that right it's a family affair
i got a great joke about your wife being
a [ __ ]
wait a minute i got a great joke about
your wife being a [ __ ] let me hear it
ah
she blew me yesterday
perfect i got a great joke about your
wife being a [ __ ] let's hear the joke
mark all right liam's a huge skank
love you ladies i'll see you in the
greek the greek single name bio
is that really how's all background
ewing was oh yeah that's not that tall
seven feet
that's not seven feet hang on
yeah
yeah he hasn't seen that
that kid that's not as big as he was
yeah is that right no that's not right
they must be i mean you got his arms
like this bigger than patrick ewings
well maybe it's not yeah i don't know
false advertising that is weird i never
thought i don't know because you ever
meet a basketball player they're like
look at how much bigger my hand is than
patrick
yeah that can't be right there you're
right
now do dicks
that's great
yeah he was [ __ ] huge that could be
right then
i went to a uh
horn no pelicans game with hannibal once
and i we he got me first row front row
on the field or wouldn't i would he on
the court the field jesus courtside and
it was just like avatars you're like
they look so huge dude james harden is
legit a big dude yeah yeah he's not tall
but he's like he's he's large his arms
are big and he is quick as
[ __ ]
he is a specimen that's the only person
i've ever seen
i saw michael jordan play once really
well here's the interesting story about
that
man's cut to me man's cut to me um
so i i told sugar at one time we were
doing two bears and i said
he said what's a show what's one of the
most memorable shows you've ever had and
i said i saw nirvana play in tallahassee
jesus you saw nirvana play i said yes
smashing pumpkins open for him and he
goes it doesn't
it doesn't seem like that would have
been real
and when it doesn't feel real but i have
the memory
no they were after him and so and so he
said
he said
you should check that out i said what's
the point of checking it out
because i have the memory right i
remember it interesting that's the only
thing you really want is the memory
right it's a fond memory i have so if i
check it out i find out it's now a false
memory i lose it entirely but right now
i have it i don't know and he says oh no
hear me out hear me out he says he says
well what's by the way we should have
put this on the podcast this is gonna so
you should be saving this let's save it
save it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah save it i'll save it i'll save
it i'll save it
all that patrick hewing stuff is fun too
i don't know
the measuring yourself against him yeah
we're saving
[Laughter]
wow
that's not the funnest language to speak
these days no no no
really yeah okay
all right all right let's rock
shall we they might be drunk they're
definitely getting drunk yeah
all right hey hey folks here we are we
might be drunk this is it the pod we're
here we're queer we're shirtless kind of
looks good those are those are good
looking chests yeah
do you know look at how sad mine is like
this ah yeah you got a little flop over
with the tip
it's like with the pizza when it flops
yeah that's your stomach are you going
shirtless are you gonna hang in there
i'm gonna look disgusting about
shirtless like this no no you look all
right no guys i will look disgusting it
will not it's you know what it is it's
uh it's when it it it doesn't look funny
anymore you're like
it's concerning yeah yeah so like i in
order to be shirtless right now i'm
really fat i'm not the fattest i've ever
been i'm losing weight but i'm really
fat
and when i when i need to be standing
shirtless i look okay yeah the second i
sit and you see my gut hang over my belt
you're like
well they did a study and the man bod
was the hottest body to females
the man-boggling the man imagine that
the man bond
[Laughter]
that can't be true give it a good peters
i'm telling they did a whole stuff who
are these realistic women
yeah they're right that doesn't sound
that doesn't sound right women feel
small women i think women are woo
here's the problem when you're sexist
you have to be careful and i think i
might be sexist i don't know i don't
know but but i'm i'm saying i don't know
but my wife says i'm sexist all the time
one time she said you want to hear this
there's a [ __ ] room that's usually
people are like my wife says i'm not
sexist you're going there my daughter
said that i they don't like the way i
represent women and material oh really
who [ __ ] listens to them they're
women but um
but uh
uh so one time we were getting on uh we
were on a plane right we had the exit
rose i had the single exit row and leah
leanne had the uh two-person exit oh
yeah right and so she was by herself in
the two person and she was and the
single was available and a dude came up
next to me like a tall dude and he sat
in front of leanne and i said
i say hey man
uh my wife's
sitting by herself over here would you
like to take my he was like six seven
like would you like to take my extra row
seat and i'll sit over with my wife he
was like hey thanks man and my wife said
um it's interesting you s you only saw
that one man you only saw that man you
know there were tall women that walked
by you and i said i said okay she was
but they they weren't attractive so they
have no value to you but they weren't
six seven they weren't six seven and by
the way what am i supposed to go hey big
[ __ ]
are your knees on the back of this guy's
guard and i was like what so she lit me
up for that i've been lit up front he
was but he was sitting next to her and
so he's sitting in front of her in front
of her and his legs are like this so i
said i'll sit with my wife you sit back
here and so my wife's but they've said
i've seen you also if you're trading
seats it has to be an appealing trade
he's tall it's an appealing trade yeah
good price that's not f that's not not
feminist yeah well i've been let up for
other stuff too um
the what was the one oh what is what i
was gonna say
it's like you know how women can have
sex and not have an orgasm and go but
i'm i still enjoy it sure well i could
never say that i hear that although i
could never be like no
yeah
wait am i the only one that that said
too no no no no as i said that i went
wait did i just help myself
no i don't have to have orgasms it was
great you know they say that all the
time they're very nice
this happens to every guy
i don't like girth i get all that
i bring the vibrator in now because i
want to you know it's like a good set
you want to do well so i bring the
vibrator in just to make sure we're all
good
like if i don't satisfy her i get the
vibe in there i'm licking a nip while
vibing it's like a good set yeah you
want to kill yeah oh wow look at this
this looks pretty delicious [ __ ]
awesome nice job beer juice i just saw
you got you guys on uh uh two bears uh
one cave when tom seguro found out you
drink like a gallon of kool-aid a day
yeah
so today we've got a gallon of cream
cheetos and kool-aid genius oh i charged
it up a little bit with some myth and
saint germain and a little soda
i love it
it's really good oh my god
oh that's delightful this is a problem
this is this is a legit problem this
tastes like childhood but it's adult
this is like driving in the desert
because you're like you don't see any
roads be like i can't get hurt
this is going to sneak up on you
i let it i want it to oh that's good
i want to be like jack the ripper i'll
be walking down a cobblestone street
because my my father has a consumption
you might not be a feminist if jack the
ripper is your example for
[Laughter]
i wrote one one pro uh woman joke in my
act but it's about stinky [ __ ]
so i don't i don't think it translates
yeah i just don't i don't think like
i'm not
i well you know when people okay here's
a question
can you get better
you know like like but no but can you
like if you think something like if
someone's a racist yeah yeah like can
you ever fix a racist because they're
always gonna think the thing
i i think the same thing like if you're
a pedophile
you can not act on it but you still want
to [ __ ] kids it's in you
you need okay hopefully it's not in you
no no i'm in the kid
you need you need a real act you need
active like uh what's it called
cognitive behavioral therapy yeah you
need it to happen to you for you to
change and you have to want to change
it's like being an alcoholic so like i
love my daughters i love and having
daughters change the way i remember the
first thing my first step out of sexism
because i think when i'm no joke no joke
i'm joking about obviously the sexism
stuff but no joke when i met leanne i
was definitely sexist i was really oh
actually i was actually sexist like i
had a problem with women because i've
been hurt by them so much
i was like every broken dude that's
about to leave a comment right now yeah
it was like those guys
and the thing about those both ways
think about the racist though like every
racist movie like american history x
they befriend a black guy in prison and
they're like oh i cannot be racist now
that's right but i don't think that
works with pedophiles i think you just
meet like one ugly kid and you're like
i'm good you know yeah yeah that's true
you get one kid to really talk some
sense into you
hey man like just so you know this is
going to break me yeah the rest of my
life and then and then you're like don't
ruin this for me uh yeah don't ruin this
yeah you don't meet the kid in prison
they separate you right
right god you ever think thank god like
i do gratitudes every morning all the
time thank god i'm not attracted to
children it's because it's not a choice
if it was a choice you would just go oh
i don't want to be that this is probably
what they drink though honestly by the
way if you're looking to [ __ ] a kid this
is the cocktail yeah if michael jackson
had two more of these
i don't know if we would have gotten
home alone too we should sell these in a
juice box we'll call this michael's hard
lemonade yeah michaels
can i tell you that's why i like being
around you guys because you guys are the
funniest [ __ ] guys in new york you
are the two funniest comics working
without a [ __ ] doubt but it's a lot
my wife will never get it
because she goes
she's like what are you doing tonight
and i said i'm going up mark and sam
we're going to have drinks and she's
like
but you're gonna slow down and i was
like yeah but how can i slow down when i
have the opportunity to laugh my [ __ ]
dick off well we don't have to you know
next time you know if you want to come
back we don't have to drink yeah we do
yeah yeah
yeah
you're the two funnest drinking guys
around there's not a lot of us left we
were talking about it's a dying art a
lot of sober comics oh yeah
you guys have you guys so i so i'm the
i'm the prototype of of i have the most
sober friends probably like people who
because i partied for i've been partying
in comedy for 25 years yeah and so we've
lost a lot of dudes sure right like a
lot loft dead but then a lot of people
go sober but when they go sober they do
the 12 steps have you gotten someone
approach you with an apology yet
yeah i had a guy hit me up i grew up
with and he and he gave me this long
call about how he was shitty and the
truth was i always thought he was a
pretty fun drunk so i was kind of like
nah you were great honestly that's a
tough thing to say to someone who's
approaching you with a problem where
you're like you were fantastic there was
never a problem like someone you maybe
you're shitty to someone else yeah but
then he started saying like i talked all
this [ __ ] about you and i was like well
that wasn't too much now you're just
telling me you didn't like me i would
have left that yeah right have you do
you have a lot of
friends oh i've had i've had
i have had
uh
and i've had so many people do that
whatever step that is is that like the
tenth step nine nine step nine
coming into your mouth it's not it's not
it's not
it's a lot more to get there but
um i remember the first time i got one i
remember the first time i didn't realize
what was happening and leanne was with
me and this dude pulled me aside uh he
approached me somewhere i was somewhere
public and he came up to me and he was
like hey man i was like what's up he's
like i need to apologize to you and i
was like for what he was like i i did
this i did this i did this
bro we're fine we're brian we get a
second hang on and leanne said bert
stop i go what she goes he's apologizing
to you and i went yeah i know but i'm
cool i don't have a problem and she goes
no bert i don't think he's doing this
for you i think he's doing this for
himself and i went what and then he was
like i'm recently sober i'm just trying
to make amends and and
it was awesome and i'll tell you why and
i i just realized this
i got to actually decide if i wanted to
forgive him
because you don't know normally when
people apologize for she just come so
quick to you you're like yeah whatever
whatever and i sat with him and i went
okay i was like in my head i was like i
had a lot of good times drinking with
this guy i had a lot the last time he
was a mess he was a little complicated
and he was he was a pain in the ass
but it doesn't overweigh the other ones
and i went buddy i forgive you i'm glad
you're doing well keep on this journey
you seem very clear-headed and and
[ __ ] awesome and then and then i've
had ones that i haven't accepted
i've had a couple that i have i've said
i do not accept your apology i
appreciate it were they consistently bad
drunks it
was the worst human beings i've ever
come in contact with oh really yeah yeah
yeah yeah just uh bad they've been
personality traits yeah and the alcohol
was part of it but that they don't lose
the personality trait kicks it out and
so i've actually said i don't accept
your apology i don't want you in my life
yeah i've had a lot of people i've had a
lot of people get sober i've had people
get sober i i dude i've had people get
sober and lie about it i've seen that
that's the good one when they're like
everyone's like no no no that person's
sober and i'm like i got in trouble one
time because i called him out wait is
schwartzen did he go sober
i think he's taking a break oh that's
good yeah i don't know i don't know i
like a break because sober is such a
commitment it's a life-changing event i
like a break i wouldn't mind a break
that like
i i i could use a break right now if i'm
just touring so hard i don't really have
an opportunity but i took a break on the
road last week uh for a chunk of days
like three days yeah which is is
it's amazing how [ __ ] rejuvenated you
are i know
how do you do it how do you do the road
as hard as you do and not in the
mornings are you not hurting mm-hmm
that's what i was gonna say don't take
this the wrong way please but i think if
you were thin
you would be in worse shape iron i think
the belly there can soak up booze it can
uh absorb interesting because if you
were thin you'd be dead
possibly i think i got something here
here's i'll tell you i was talking to
someone about it the other day i have a
very punitive sense of sense of uh
sensibility so what does that mean uh
when i wake up if i'm hungover
i i get angry with myself and i go you
you earned this [ __ ] now why don't we
get out of bed and get something done
today why don't we [ __ ] go do
something
and for lately like when on the road
it's disc golf when i'm at home i get on
my treadmill and i go five miles man you
earned it let's go get on the treadmill
and then once i get on the treadmill
once my blood starts flowing it all kind
of goes away and so best thing for you
and i also started a happiness journal
to try to figure out and highlight the
things that make me happy
i've been i've been on a little bit of a
growth kick
after i got covered when i got covered i
got hung over i drank [ __ ] hard as
[ __ ] the night i got covered then i woke
up the next morning and i was like what
the [ __ ] dude i'm i'm like i think i'm
done i had covered i thought it was a
hangover yeah and i was like i [ __ ]
this is a bad hangover like i was shaky
and my back hurt and all of a sudden i
can't smile anymore yeah taste i was
like i gotta quit [ __ ] drinking
and and then and so i quit drinking for
like 10 you know obviously 10 days
whatever [ __ ] code is and um
and in that 10 days i was like i need to
assess
what i need to highlight things that
make me happy and focus on them and i
was dealing with so much bad [ __ ] like
so like things where it could [ __ ] me up
right or obsessed about it in regards to
it
and i was like i gotta get rid of those
things and highlight oh that's not real
that's not
that's not real i need to not focus on
that and so i did it and in the process
i realized when i'm sober i'm pretty
[ __ ] lazy
i'm the same way i wake up and i go i
feel good i'm gonna have a breakfast
burrito right when i woke up hungover i
go i'm not eating today i woke up
hungover obviously we partied all night
didn't i had one piece of pizza last
night woke up didn't eat until 1 30.
there you go yeah because because my and
i told you i said i looked at it and i
went you don't deserve that that's
punitive
pizza the night of drinking like it's
it's necessary if i don't eat before i
go to bed i'm dead dead you gotta soak
it up
yeah i have a weird [ __ ] brain though
like i don't i like i wouldn't want my i
wouldn't want anyone else to have my
brain my daughters have my brain and i
feel bad for them because they have
my you know i was just telling you about
the [ __ ]
the um smashing pumpkins yeah yeah this
is how my brain thinks uh-oh
i've said this and this guy i'm sure
that some [ __ ] psychologists will be
like oh he's a narcissist or whatever
i'm sure there's a term for me
so i was talking to screw we're doing
two bears one cave i don't know if you
heard this but we were talking about um
nirvana the greatest shows we ever saw i
saw i saw nirvana open for smashing or
smashing moments open for nirvana at the
civic center in tallahassee in
1995 94 maybe 93 and he was like
really and you know skirt is like a
literal person and he's like it doesn't
seem like they would have opened for
them should we google this so you don't
want to know by the way you can actually
but here's what happened so i go well
hold on
i have that memory yeah and and
sometimes with memories you don't
remember it right you kind of punch up
the memory as you live you're like yes
and so
why do we do that so we have we think we
had a more interesting life yeah i think
it helps you
but but in the in the end does it matter
say you have a boring life but you
remember a great life but this is good
in a positive experience but what if
some kid goes hey you molested me and
you're like no i didn't he's like that's
what i remember now you're [ __ ] well
that does happen with you were a bully
in high school and you're like no i
wasn't and you're like yeah you were and
then you're like i know
come on fat back what are you talking
about so so i said to tom
i said no i i remember
nirvana played the civic center i was
there
smashing pumpkins open for them and i
said and i go i can very easily check
this out i'll call my buddy john daker
i'll ask him if nirvana ever played the
civic center if we saw them and he was
like i said or do i want to want to run
the risk of losing that memory i have
the memory i have it it's real in my
head whether or not it really happened i
don't know it doesn't matter do i run
the risk and then i said
i saw jordan play basketball but i don't
know if that's real well cause it's
because it's a memory and you're like
memories are always fading and i'm like
i'm like wait
and i go i don't want to find out the
truth and he was like we weren't doing
too embarrassed he's like we gotta find
the truth call john daker i go hey man
and by the way this is like rolling the
dice because i'm [ __ ] gonna be really
bummed if i never saw nirvana this is my
favorite bands
i believe you saw nirvana i just don't
know if you saw the pumpkins yeah this
pumpkins so i called john daker
i said hey man did we see nirvana
did we do have we ever seen nirvana
concert he said miu and daker saw
nirvana at the civic center and i said
oh my god and he goes yeah smashing
pumpkins opened up for him and i went oh
and now by the way i didn't here's the
deal
i didn't feel better and he's like we
both [ __ ] courtney love that night
like i don't know if that happened but
that's how i remember it i just told
kurt cobain a shotgun i didn't feel
better
knowing that it was real it didn't
change
interesting however i ran the risk of
losing a great memory so i will never
google i like if i saw michael jordan
play basketball in 1997
in orlando i will never google that wow
well he was still playing then i will
never
and don't you pull it up on this [ __ ]
thing and don't you if you're listening
do not google yeah
but it's weird when people do this to
benefit them they're like oh i did a
show last night and i killed and you're
there you're thinking like i was there
you bombed yeah but they have to do that
to well that's like we all did that
early in comedy oh yeah when i'm like
i'm like that that was all right and
then you listen to tape and you're like
i can't i mean i can't listen to this
it's the strip club that she's into me i
can tell she's into me and you're all
your friend's like oh god
pulled out 1400 would you rather be
accurate or delusional i mean how much
fun do you think it would be i don't
know i'm going to say the guy's name but
you know who were talking about at
stand-up clubs they're like our [ __ ]
rock that room that's what would it be
nice to be that [ __ ] guy and walk off
and it hurts your comedy if you're that
delusional you're not you're not
connecting right true okay so do you
want to be us i [ __ ] i hate my act i
hate everything i do and this is that
it's good to hate your act i think a
little bit a healthy a healthy amount of
hatred if you hate it a little bit it
keeps you going i mean you write a new
hour every year and a half right how
hard it is sometimes to say the words
that i'm thinking that i put like i have
this bit right now that's
murdering
so good and that's like last night it
didn't happen
but the smashing pumpkins were there and
that was pretty cool yeah they killed
but i and then and then i need a second
part to it because it's a two-part bit
it's one part and i got the beats down
early it's easy to get a story going in
the beginning to get a story getting
going is great but to end the story is
so [ __ ] hard and i need to end it i
need to end it right now i'm saying and
then i [ __ ] my pants
you know [ __ ] angry that makes me
those words come out of my mouth and i
[ __ ] in my shoe
you're gonna get it it takes so long
because you had that white night story
and it was your white whale you text me
over like a five year span you're like
what about this what about this what do
you but some of your stories you have
the ending and you kind of just fell out
the middle though right um so i got
great ending i have a great ending i
have a great the yeah i got great ending
from sometimes if i recognize a story i
go
the ending is what you notice first and
you go oh i just got to write the front
part and yeah then sometimes you'll get
loose on the front part it won't be as
good but you just kind of get once you
have the ending you're set you're set
because people with a story they want to
know it's over yes they want but i've
gotten too nifty with that it's like sex
they want to see they want to be like
you came right yeah
that's why no one comes inside anyone
because you don't trust them yeah like
in porno in pornos i mean right right
you never see the guy go
i remember one time i was in i was in
calgary i had this i i just these two
let me say these two good jokes um
uh
my daughter isla is a weirdo she puts
her deodorant in the refrigerator wow
oh you ever heard this job that's a
great idea oh it's well no no no oh so i
said to leanne she put some i'll tell
you the joke uh but it's i've already
done it she puts her name in the
refrigerator her deodorant refrigerator
and puts her name on the cap a cap and
the base of the deodorant and so is not
to confuse it with all the other
deodorants
so said leona go what the [ __ ]
up with the island she was you know i
love and i said no apparently i don't so
one morning i'm making coffee isla comes
in
and she looks she's on the sly she looks
at me and sees i'm not looking she opens
the refrigerator she takes out her
deodorant she wipes her finger across it
rubs above her lip and puts it in the
thing shuts the door and i go what the
[ __ ] was that she goes mind your own
business whoa
so now so now here's the so that was
that was kind of that story right
i had another story about isla
where i talked about her one time i ate
an edible and i just mashed it up a
little bit i changed a little bit of it
but i ate an edible and i went to bed
and isla woke me up i wasn't sleeping i
was way too high she came up next to me
in the middle of the night she goes dad
do you believe in time travel this is
like [ __ ] two in the morning i i'm
holding on to the [ __ ] bed trying to
[ __ ] go to sleep
and she goes do you believe in time
travel by the way i really believe in
time travel i believe more in time
travel than i do in death right so i go
i go yes why and she goes that's all i
need to know good night and she leaves
whoa that's trippy well so but they were
okay bits right well i get drunk one
night in calgary and i and i [ __ ] them
up and i mash them up and i turn it into
one bit
where i then tell them together
my daughter says do you blame trouble
yeah she goes that's all i need to know
she leaves now i'm on the edge going
what like there's got to be a 30 year
old version of herself in her bedroom
going what did he say yeah she goes he
said it's true and she goes i told you
to listen your dad's gonna die but we're
gonna save him what i need to do is take
your deodorant put it in the
refrigerator
because
the joke was
she when she did this
she said i can't trust that everyone's
going to put on deodorant so i'm just
doing it for them so she would put yoda
so that no one smelled like [ __ ] for the
day she got to pick what she smelled
right such a weird [ __ ] brain but
when i mashed him up i had the end i
tell it in calgary i get the end time
travel smells like [ __ ] we needed to
take the door and put in the fridge and
they applauded and i when i got off
stage there was i wish i knew who this
[ __ ] kid that i worked with was she
was such a good comic for four years he
was so good and he goes i go dude they
applauded that joke and he went yeah i
did too and i went why he goes because
it was over
oh
are you being serious and he goes well
yeah when something's when someone
finishes something you're like wow that
was really good and you're like
holy [ __ ]
that [ __ ] me up
for like hey big boy you will notice
every one of my bits is ta-da
yeah
every bit had
isn't that crazy when you you [ __ ] up a
bit and it helps it on accident yeah
that's why you got to do the road a lot
because you never know yeah because
you're just tired and your brain shuts
off and you say something by accident
and you're like oh [ __ ] that's yeah the
joke's better because i'm i'm dumber
just right just flipping wording around
one time like i have this joke about
isla right now where she gets up turns
around
um
says
seven hundred eight hundred dollars six
hundred dollars
and proceeds to have a stroke and i just
i just [ __ ] up the wording yeah and it
got such better because i crammed
everything in and then sometimes you
know that your wording isn't great and
you're like
wait
i i know that this isn't perfect but
it's good enough and i don't want to
[ __ ] with it yes yes you know totally
yeah sometimes you just have to say it
it's like we're talking about hating our
ex sometimes when you say it until
you're sick of it you're just kind of
going through the motions and you almost
need that it's almost like someone it's
like you can't have great sex every
night sometimes it's going through the
motion sex you know yes and and going
through the motion sex it's like okay
well this keeps you
able to like know how to have sex that's
right i don't know if this analogy makes
any sense no we were talking about what
you don't always have wet [ __ ] sex
yeah you have the hey we'll get the wet
[ __ ] sex and it's the same you don't
have to always have a huge boner sex
sometimes it's a happy and you mush it
in well i kind of like that though that
is fine
i like starting off kind of soft and
getting harder yeah throughout it she
knows that and she will she'll say this
was creepy about my wife and she got she
go i know you like this
but that comfort isn't is important man
just having that and sometimes you're
doing so many gigs that you just flub a
line and it helps you and you're like
[ __ ] i
you know what's another big one is uh is
falling out of love with a bit you know
you're like i love this bit uh then like
two years later it's just a regular old
bit and then you can see it clearer it's
like a a woman when you're in love with
her you don't notice her flaws and
whatever and then when you fall out of
love you're like ah she's this she's
that same with a bit
yeah you can kind of see it re in
reality you ever do that you ever just
have a joke and a word document or
something and then you and you shelve it
for two years yeah you're back and
you're like you're like oh young me
didn't understand how to handle this
exactly
yeah yeah
i
a joke i wrote when i first started
doing stand-up like when i was working
the door was
i'm not homo i'm not homophobic i'm a
homochondriac
hello and and i but i couldn't that's
where i left it and then in one of my
specials i said i figured it out after i
i was like i'm not homophobic i'm a
homochondriac i'm not afraid of you
being gay i'm just afraid one night
we'll get get drunk and you'll trick me
into it and i'll like it that's great
like and so i was like oh that works
there we go but you're right louis did
that louis was a big guy of of going
back to his earlier stop yes and [ __ ]
re-figuring it out that's basically
comedy time travel the problem is the
problem is if you are
that's great for guys who find their
voice very early
but if i went back to my old bits it
would just be me reworking dane cook's
hour because like all my early bits were
like a mashup of dane cook and dave
attell right like that's all and any
comic that says they weren't mashups of
those two they were the most
dane cook i don't think he gets the
proper credit that he deserves he's a
beast he was he defined
he showed us he showed his way through
the jungle where no tigers were and no
one had that thank you no one had that
everyone attel got attacked by tigers
all the time he always got out of the
jungle jim norton
actually made a living letting tigers
jump at him and then [ __ ] throwing
them off right
tigers so like
so
so
bombing is tigers okay okay guys showed
us a way through the jungle where you
but where you didn't bomb yeah like i'm
it's the only person i've ever seen in
stand-up comedy that
went on with the confidence of an ice
skater knowing they're gonna stick all
their [ __ ] moves dane cook was was
still is still is so [ __ ]
adept
at so charismatic that no one gives him
enough credit for how [ __ ]
influential he was sure i'll i won't
name names but it's tough when you
because i agree with you but i think it
is tough when your career goes like this
as opposed to this because i do think he
blew up so big that it's almost like
it's unsustainable there's nowhere to go
but down yeah he did he didn't i don't
think he never ever did theaters i think
he just went straight to arenas yeah
that's crazy
he went to the from the orlando improv
to the [ __ ] arena in orlando damn
insane but yeah it sucks to be in
orlando but
cut two cut two i do
i do the tallahassee civic center the
right
and now i know for a fact and i got to
see there i sat i sold the same amount
of ticks as [ __ ] nirvana and i looked
at the seat i sat in with john baker and
brent bracken in that [ __ ] civic
center and i knew it was a real thought
i knew it was a real memory but i was
like i sat right there and watched
nirvana stand on this stage in this same
setup it was [ __ ] it was surreal come
out to a nirvana song no that's a nice
[ __ ] that's great i should have
traveled go do it again i don't believe
i do believe more in time travel than i
do death oh you're crazy yeah you said
that before i don't understand how don't
believe in death i don't believe it
really i don't believe that i don't
believe in it i don't believe this is
this is a work worst take than whoopi
nope i don't believe in it i'm not gonna
believe in it i refuse to believe in it
all right because when it happens i'm
not gonna feel it i guess right so
wouldn't it be better just to just not
believe in it
right and then just and then when it
happens you're like well i guess i was
wrong
as opposed to thinking about it every
morning when you wake up are those going
to be that's going to be on your
tombstone i was wrong yeah yeah
carlin had the best tombstone it just
says well he was he was here a minute
ago
that's the best tombstone ever
i don't know if funerals aren't any of a
cool thing anymore no one does funerals
what are you talking about no one does
funerals
that's true because you mean like zoom
no no no no no no one's doing funerals
i've had a few friends die and no one
does funerals for them
they're just like they're like yeah i'm
like well they were suicide so maybe
they'll do funerals for suicides comics
should do funerals the way they did it
on the wire where you just throw someone
on a pool table and you get drunk the
wake the way yeah i love that the wire
funerals are awesome yeah that's irish
[ __ ] i wanted to have a funeral for my
50th birthday party
like i wanted to sit in the casket right
but the cat's going to be tilted up so i
can see everyone
[Laughter]
and then i want to invite
oh i want i'm it's an open invite right
i want to see who shows up
i want to experience my funeral so and i
want people to come and i want people to
talk i'm gonna have cigarette talk i'm
gonna have rogan say some words i'm
gonna have my friends say some words it
makes sense i wanna hear what they're
gonna say i wanna be there i wanna see
how fun it is because patrice had the
best funeral in the world but he didn't
get to see it that's true i mean so why
not yeah why not it's tom sawyer that's
the mark twain book he gets to see his
own funeral is this true rich rich vos
at patrice's funeral said he'll be
selling cds outside
that's the funniest thing i've ever
heard the funniest line i've ever heard
is dave attell on opium anthony yes
and he goes come on people we need a
double extra large coffin and a big
purple suit
because it was all uncomfortable and sad
and he brought that line in and broke
the tension it was amazing
until it was my first night back at the
cellar after covid it was like a couple
weeks ago and uh i just walk in if he's
on stage i'm like let me wait for a big
laugh so he doesn't see me so i dig in
and as i i think i made it through he
goes feeling better sam and then just
goes right back in the material
that was for nobody
yeah
it was just for him to dig me when i was
a young comic i was walking through the
back of the cellar and i had a hawaiian
shirt on and he goes hey
hawaiian shirts only two people wear
hawaiian shirts homosexuals and party
animals which one are you and i am i'm
such a jackass i went i'm a party animal
[Laughter]
that's a shame the funniest thing i ever
saw him do and there's a million things
but there was two hispanic women in the
front row who weren't laughing at
anything and he sees them immediately
and just goes what happened ladies did
selena die again
we all [ __ ] lost it
he is the greatest i could just do he's
the greatest yeah he is the best the
goat he's
you know call me the greatest i will
[ __ ] give you a hug
you say bird is the greatest storyteller
around i'd be like thank you
someone noticed that i can see how it's
annoying
because he's always doing new [ __ ] so
i'm sure it annoys him like you know uh
i remember watching craig ferguson once
and he was like this is the greatest
comedian ever and you could just see
dave was furious now he's gotta he's
gonna live up to that right oh i wish he
had a little more
uh louie in him or whatever he would
just do a special every year or or every
other year like put some of this [ __ ]
down on tv i'll tell you what i'd say
i'll tell you what i would do if i was
netflix i would do give him a half hour
i'd i'd sign david tell i'd sign david
tell okay here's my pitch if robbie
prawl is listening here's my piss he's
not
if he is
uh
10 million deal
for 10 years okay
um just give him 10 right up front 10
million now right
10 years and dave attell has to release
a special every quarter
whatever he's working on we get to see
it every quarter oh he would hate this
why he loves well how long do you think
attel can turn over
okay how about
well every six months rep all right by
the way i don't need big production i
just like a camera
in the cellar to shoot that put it on
netflix every six months and just turn
material turn material this podcast
turns into talking about a tell so much
here's my picture isn't that crazy
here's my pitch for dave insomniac but
in the daytime it's sober dave like just
do insomniac like he used to do but he's
just all the same stuff but it's it's
daytime yeah you know that's funny he's
doing a lemonade stand he's buying girl
scout cookies
the zoo you know i don't know but i
think he wakes up at five
how how about this how about this you
might not like this pitch what if david
tells starts a podcast and talks about
us
all right let's change subjects all
right all right
did you watch the oscars no what
happened
[Music]
that [ __ ] slapped it was great do you
think he was drunk
will smith
i think they're all drunk there i think
he's going through a lot he's he's in
scientology his wife's [ __ ] other
dudes but they think the booze pushes
you over the
maybe maybe but i think i think you do
that sober i think you have to have at
least a couple they don't feed you there
i don't even know if he drinks rage is
different
rages is different have you ever
been
raised so i got in control of my here's
what i was fascinated by and i apologize
to monopolize this but like
hyper aware of being uh videotaped
i'm hyper aware of it because i have
[ __ ] up a couple times where i was
videotaped and and i was afraid it was
going to get leaked where i behaved
poorly sure and so i'm hyper aware so
when when we went to red rocks remember
we went to red rocks yep then that lady
talked [ __ ] to me and and everyone lost
their [ __ ] minds we were trying to
get to a to our van after the jimmy
buffet show yeah and everyone lost their
mind i'm hyper aware that there are
people with cameras so i stay grounded
in those moments i'm really good at
putting off rage i i cut this lady off
one time i didn't didn't even know i did
it i actually thought she caught me off
but the point was there was i knew that
i wasn't gonna
she was so angry and she
pulled up
and she had her phone out and she was
recording me
and she was like you [ __ ] cut me off
[ __ ]
and i was so aware that i was being
recorded and i was like i and i actually
believe she cut me off but i also knew i
wasn't going to change her mind like at
no point was she going to go
oh wait you're right maybe that was red
i wasn't paying attention
i just went i'm so sorry i'm really
sorry i wasn't paying attention you're
right i'm wrong and so i i just defused
it because i was like i don't want to be
caught and did she calm down when you
did that no
no no actually not at all it got worse
and so
and so um she called me the n-word and
took off
rogan
so uh but but that's what's amazing to
me is that rage when you're in when
you're in rage that's all the karen's
will went full karen yes he couldn't
control it right it's rage man and rages
rage is like like okay let's talk about
the feelings the best feelings in the
world
full rage when you're shaking you feel
like a superhero and you think i will
[ __ ] rip this wall down yeah that
yeah being turned on when you're like oh
my god i'm so turned on i could [ __ ]
yeah your body's vibrating um thank god
he didn't feel that toward chris that
would have been even worse
how great would he be if he just [ __ ]
just anally raped him on that stage jada
would have been like finally
that's all she wants but that was rage
it was he was drunk with rage and
and
who knows what had happened leading up
to that all the stuff leading up to it
yeah they clearly didn't like they
clearly had tension because yes because
you think about what rickles used to say
to sinatra the biggest egomaniac ever
he'd say things like hey frank make
yourself at home hit someone and sinatra
would laugh yeah so it's all about past
relationship you know well did you see
the 2016 oscars where rock trashes jada
it's pretty funny it's pretty funny but
it's like oh okay so there is some
history here she was boycotting the
oscars because will didn't get nominated
and i don't remember the joke but a joke
because it's not fair to get nominated
it's also not fair he got 20 million for
wild wild west and then that's not fair
she goes uh he's like you're not
boycotting you weren't invited i'm not
boycotting rihanna's panties
that's an edgy joke for the oscars i
know that's one you probably can't get
away with these days no it was a
different time just 2016 to now is is
vastly different with jokes ricky
gervais is the best yeah he put on an
alopecia joke do you see that no yeah
yeah what did he say he just had a clip
from him on the office or whatever one
of his shows and he did an alopecia joke
and he just posted it he's so good it's
also unfortunate she has alopecia but
it's not like you know it's not bad it's
not she doesn't get her she's also got
great head shape privilege there's some
people that go bald and have like dents
and it looks like their head was beating
with the shovel and you have to live
like that jeff ross for example
but that's not yeah i don't know well
it's gotta be weird i mean like i'm
trying to be empathetic to alopecia yeah
but like it's gotta be weird like so
when you have a she has alopecia she has
no hair anywhere on her body no no no no
it hits you in certain areas yeah oh so
it's just thinning yeah and she shaves
it it falls out okay so it could come
back she's brought so much awareness to
alopecia i know it's huge for them yeah
but it's not like there's an alopecia
group somewhere we're acting like it's
[ __ ] there's gotta be uh no they're
definitely what are you talking about i
think there's groups with alopecia yeah
marching and [ __ ] i don't know if
they're marching but maybe they're
meeting what are they meeting about you
lost your hair me too i'll see you later
type in there's someone google alopecia
foundation is there a support gotta be
oh
hold on there's one for everything what
if this is alopecia awareness month how
that would be probably national alopecia
arena foundation basin san rafael
current treatment of alopecia oh get out
of here it was found in 1981 that's kind
of oh that's pretty old
yeah wow miss california had it huh geez
all right see you can still prosper
i have alopecia
i do i get in my beard like oh really
yeah but
that was yeah yeah exactly that was i
thought it was a joke we're really just
getting a little a little fuzzy on the
medical condition i mean that should be
reserved for big [ __ ]
yeah medical condition like all right
well everything's a medical impotency is
a medical condition is it not yeah well
yeah what if that was the joke he
slapped him for oh will can't get his
dick up and he just got him walked up
and slapped him like oh i guess that's
real here's what i think i think he's
been kind of uh cucked for a while
everybody's making fun of your wife's
[ __ ] all these dudes and he can't hit
her so when chris rock says something
he's like i'll channel it all to this
yeah because i'm i'm already kind of
getting made fun of
that's gotta be tough to be to have all
that he has and then publicly you have
to deal with that because that and i i'm
gonna be really honest i'm not a fan of
that i don't like i don't like
this is what's tough for me and i've
talked about this on two bears a lot i'm
a [ __ ] will smith ride or die like
i'm
first and foremost he gave me my he gave
me my very first development deal yeah
and he taught me how to sell tv shows he
had such a big impact on me
in this business and and and his calling
card the fact that he was the one that
kind of gave me my first deal was like
it meant a lot to me and so through all
of this
including the slap i was like because i
mean you know immediately i go to rock
i'm like i'm i'm a comedian
and you can't hit someone under any
circle like was it was it a great joke
no but you can't hit
someone under any circumstances right
but i but i
i haven't enjoyed this uh i'll say this
i'm gonna show you the most polite way
that if will ever heard this with robbie
prawl
um
i'm i have not enjoyed this red table
[ __ ] show i don't think it's i think
what is it are you being serious yeah it
is
it is the [ __ ] worst god damn show uh
i [ __ ] hate it because it's basically
jada's table where she
kind of has they they talk their family
stuff out
oh and it's where
entanglement comes from it's where all
the stuff that you're hearing that you
know about will smith is based on these
red table conversations now i'm certain
that jada would probably feel
differently about it and probably will
feel differently about it
i will say publicly as a fan of will a
ride or die for will smith i've not
enjoyed it i don't i also didn't enjoy
aunt viv coming after will do you
remember that yeah i remember i didn't
like that i didn't like that well she
was like a juilliard actress she was
kind of like i should be the star and
it's like i don't think you've seen the
show
the fresh prince not the aunt and the
fact that she's holding onto a grudge
40 years later right and and still wants
to dress him down
yes and i'm like i want to say ma'am
uh do you not i understand that your
path in hollywood must have been very
tough being over black actress in the
[ __ ] 70s and 80s
however you have been in this business
long enough to understand that he is he
is a rising star and the world [ __ ]
them up and they do [ __ ] up things
because they don't really have any
boundaries and and what he did wasn't
horrible
but but you were difficult also you have
to realize your account i didn't like
that i didn't like that i like the red
table and i don't like what's happening
with will i didn't like they need a
[ __ ] youtube channel i don't like any
of that [ __ ] because it's fun when
celebrities are like nicholson and they
have a little more mystique yes yeah and
it's hard i mean it's but it's probably
harder and harder to do that because
when you see an actor's not on instagram
you're shocked right you're like oh wow
good for you yeah yeah yeah yeah timothy
chalamet has no social media and i'm
like good for you and he's young because
he's got a tour he's got to put on a
mask and we got to believe it yeah and
i'll tell you right now um this is what
bummed me out the most is my first
initial my two thoughts right these are
my two thoughts when i saw that slap
number one is i identify with chris rock
getting slapped i identify with that i
am that person i have been slapped for a
joke i have been slapped in high school
a couple times punched a couple times
and i got beat up one time yeah for
jokes before i was a professional
comedian yeah that's how that works i
understand the streets have their
justice share keep my name i get it but
the second he got slapped the look on
his face as he tried to read the
documentary i was like i'm that guy i'm
that's me that's me in this whole
scenario that's who i identify with
that's my i'm that person we always
identify as a com with a comic totally i
remember i got punched in the face once
i was i was insulting uh
i was insulted a woman i was talking to
a girl the boy many years ago i was in
my early 20s on the road and uh i was
uh talking to a girl and her friend kept
leaning in and being like not interested
everything like just kept insulting me
and finally i said like get some more
botox you lizard like just instinct
drunk and her and her boyfriend just
decked me and i was like i deserved it i
mean like it's what happened but it also
is like you know yeah
it is also like ah violet it shouldn't
be violent right
we're living in my head i thought i
deserved it but then looking back like
violence is not
that's not right the second thing i
thought was this is going to change
how everyone sees will smith for the
rest of his life isn't that [ __ ] up
this bumper there's like me out it
bumped me out i went
you can't
you're not going to be able to ruined an
otherwise what what should have been an
incredible night for him because it's
like it's like his iou one oscar because
like he didn't get it for uh
what else is he nominating
or something whatever yeah he yeah but
like they're like oh he's been a star
for so long he's like a dude they want
to give it to yeah and they and they
gave it to him and then they they took
away a career like no he's still going
to be huge
you don't think so no no i think so
interesting
nope you're going to go to a movie
and you're going to see will smith and
all you're going to think about is the
guy that slap chris rock dude
when you when you resort to violence you
define who you are to everyone you show
everyone you are not you are not you are
below all of us that is the deal you
make dude i tell a joke i tell a joke in
college i wrote a song
to uh uh pink houses by uh
john mellencamp
i've talked about this a little bit
maybe i've really talked in depth about
it um
but uh it was just rhyming uh his name
is hartley he's hiv
his name is hartley he
std baby his name is hartley
he's gonna and so and why that's my
buddy i can say that joke besides my
buddy he didn't get upset but i made
another one about another guy in our
fraternity and it was innocuous but he
didn't get it because he's because
that's why his brain works he's not not
the guy that gets it he gets emotional
and rage fills him and one day right
before finals he beats the [ __ ] out of
me whoa
uh we get into a sky i don't really
remember much of it because i got
knocked unconscious but he grabbed all i
know is smashing pumpkins open though
yeah
he beats me uh up i
then am confused i walk onto campus
um and a girl finds me sitting on a
bench in campus crying and i don't know
who i am i don't know where i am i don't
know what's going on oh my god and i'm
like repeating i'm full fully concussed
whoa and she knows me she's a pie pie
and she grabs me she puts me in she had
a minivan i remember that she drove me
out to the hospital uh they asked me
uh where i went to school and i said
jesuit which is my high school boy and
they're like whoa what happened to you
and she's like i don't know he's he's
not i don't i don't remember what
happened
my roommate were you drunk no no stone
snipers during finals i was supposed to
be taking finals
my roommate and my girlfriend at the
time find out on my thought someone
calls calls they find them at the
hospital they grab me they they keep me
in the hospital i think overnight
i then come in
and i will say this
unequivocally
that dude
lost a lot of friends that day yeah that
have never spoken to him since
and it changed the way everyone saw that
dude for the rest of his life now he may
not feel that now right but i'm certain
to say
that with my career where it is today
and and when i go and perform in tampa
he lives to live in tampa i'm certain
that it
that there are there's awkwardness
around him definitely and so and so once
you resort to violence and you show
everyone oh i i don't use words anymore
i this is how i handle things man you
might get respect to some people right
for the wrong people the wrong people
the people you don't want and especially
if you're a [ __ ] artist how about how
about the whole academy how spineless
they are that they give him a standing
ovation when he wins the award after
doing that like how about no security
for rock like how about that we play
strip malls on the road yeah we have
better security i guess it's you don't
know he's going to go up to hit him
you're probably like what's he doing
i thought it was a joke like oh he's
going to [ __ ] with him haha that's funny
but you've got to stand up for chris
rock
more than just say we condemn this guy
who we just gave an award to i'm not
saying take the award away but
how about chris rock well did you see
the uh on youtube you can see the uh
commercial break and they're all
comforting will smith it's like well
comfort the guy got hit
but he was backstage i'm sure and here's
the part we i bet we don't know but
we'll probably hear you know they went
back to chris right you know i mean look
i can't sue him don't sue us no no no no
i'm sure they went back and they're like
how would you like to handle this yeah i
mean i just know that i've i've had
but what i've had incidents on set
before
where i've been the victim of them
simple things very simple things
and
they i mean everyone's like how do you
want to stay into this and you're like
don't don't [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah i
never probably told you yeah and so i
guarantee that went to chris rock and
like how do you want to handle this and
he was like he's like he's like i'm what
am i going to [ __ ] say he's escorted
out of the oscars and everyone's going
to be like why did you take away this
man's biggest night yeah it's a tough
spot but he's going to sell tickets
chris rock that 10 minutes
there was a part of me that's like man i
wish chris rock kind of zinged him when
he on his way back
you know the part of me i wish he just
got like one quick one liner totally but
the other part of me is like yeah he'll
have a carefully honed 10 minutes about
this that's going to be awesome it's
going to be so good and it's going to
see slapstick comedy again all right
what uh what do you call this next tour
slappy white slap her around the
world yeah
yeah that's not bad yeah
the uh
slip slap i would think i i i think i
can't wait to see him do stand up
yeah this will be in it for sure are you
excited about will smith's next project
what's that going to be
i heard he's playing ike turner
[Laughter]
and chris is going to play tina
i'm going to recreate that fresh
princess
[Laughter]
yeah it was uh it's weird you know i
think about a lot like think about how
much used to be settled with a duel like
that used to be so like you disrespected
someone's family they'd be like i'm
gonna hit you right or i'm gonna i'm
gonna shoot you yeah that's true we've
become more civilized we have violence
was so much more acceptable when i was a
kid yeah definitely it was to morons let
me say cause i remember i hit someone i
punched someone in uh the day before
ninth grade
and i
and i
went home
believing my dad was going to
put me on his shoulders and march me
around the house because he had a badass
son and by the time i got home
that guy's dad had called my dad they're
both lawyers called my dad and said your
son punched my son
uh i'm just letting you know and my dad
was [ __ ] livid really he was like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you that's a
good dad though he's like you think
you're a tough guy he's like no he goes
i'm worried because i oh you're about to
go to high school you think you're the
tough guy you think you're a [ __ ]
badass like because you're not don't
ever [ __ ] punch someone you never
[ __ ] hit someone if you have a
problem with me speak to them and i was
like okay
okay the next day i go to high school
a dude i'd grown up with my whole life
who was six six
got beaten up by a dude who was five six
the guy pulled a chair up and punched
him he pulled up a chair stood up
and i realized i'm not a tough guy next
week in the shower dude breaks a guy's
nose and i'm like i'm not tough at all
i'm not [ __ ] tough at all yeah that
[ __ ] changes next week he stepped on a
stool and raped him
so
it's terrible that [ __ ] changes you and
it's not fun and
oh [ __ ] i had a point
uh
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh now nowadays you go to a bar
and you try to do that [ __ ] and you
don't know who knows mma and all that
[ __ ] it's so popular now the jiu jitsu
and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] what a great
way to find out chris rock's been
training in
he just pulls guard like gets on his
back come on get on me he's in a weird
naked joke you just see you just see
will smith like ah yeah he puts will
smith in an omaplata
it was i'll tell you what man
it made things interesting again the
oscars were boring does that did anyone
get excited for the oscars this year no
i mean
i will be watching next year it's gonna
be fun next year when they present with
jake paul next door you know you never
know just in case something goes down
say what you want about jake paul he's
made life interesting yeah
i mean i understand people don't like
the guy i enjoy the guy i enjoy him and
his brother
they get they put the razzle dazzle back
in life yeah they're just uh [ __ ]
starters let's get it going yeah i wish
you would fight real fighters like like
that first guys i know but that first
guy ben askren is a real fighter
but he's like you saw him box and i was
like this is [ __ ] crazy you got to
start at the bottom you know you got to
work your way up he fought uh what's his
face the the black guy he's clearly a
tyranny
tyrone biggs no that's chappelle oh yeah
wow wow i hope he did not fight tyrone
bigby
that would not be a fair match woodley
although does will smith do that [ __ ] to
chappelle by the way um
interesting yeah here's mine that was a
big dude hold on is he he's pretty
bigger
hold on hold on
i mean here's the thing and then i'm
just saying this for real and i don't
mean this i don't mean this is a slight
dispel at all because it's not but like
chappelle's one of us he's not a tough
guy i mean like he didn't grow up in the
streets like
he's not mike epps i don't mean this
disrespectful right he's just one like
mike absolute comic but he's i mean i
don't think this is coming out wrong but
he's also a different type of dude i
know what you're right kevin hart and
dave chappelle they're one of us like
meaning like they're just comics they're
just comics they're just comics they
were never the tough guy or the cool guy
or the badass guy they were just like
the underdog who came up busted his ass
and they're talented and that's it i
mean
i think i mean i mean i think
kevin hart probably
experienced more toughness in his life
yeah grew up in a bad everybody had
great mom right his dad was addicted to
drugs great mom big brother so he
probably saw some stuff but i i when i
think of dave chappelle and i think of
chris rock i think they're kind of the
same type of guy the same kind of guy as
i am i might look like i could beat
someone up but i can't i'm chris rock
when he got slapped i'm chris rock right
dave's i mean i just don't i don't know
if he does it to dave chappelle because
i don't know if he does but like look
the skinny day chapelle is always been
his whole life yeah that's who he is
that's who he is inside inside and i
hope that comes out right right i'm not
like no no i get it yeah yeah like
he's got huge arms he's got [ __ ]
massive arms it's impressive you see him
in a suit now and you're like oh you
look like john cena in that suit you
don't look like i want that for my next
special look at that i want that for my
next special i just want [ __ ] jacked
arms no no fat
they say it makes you less funny jack
dorms yeah i don't think so
guys got the [ __ ] best joke i've ever
heard in my entire life kick her in the
[ __ ] that's my favorite joke i've ever
heard in my entire life that is my
favorite joke that and dave's david
david tells uh is it just me or does an
owl look like an attorney for a parrot
kicker in the [ __ ] by the way dave
spells basically shirtless there look
look how ripped that's his shoulders are
huge his arms are [ __ ] jacked hold on
yeah you're right now that i think about
that does he do it dave chappelle no
dave spells his height right describes
six foot right six yeah yeah he's
[ __ ] probably 225. and he would have
flicked his cigarette right on will
smith
oh he would have oh yeah because you
know he'd be smoking and chapelle would
but yeah but chappelle would have had
yellow glasses on mmm that could [ __ ]
you up yeah i could [ __ ] you up
interesting look at how big dave
but this is crazy this is like if you
type in um
bert christ you're in shape
and then
i don't want to complain
[Laughter]
it is crazy that the news was ukraine
every day and now oh do you just turn
any news network and it's like a
celebrity was slapped
whoa
that's not real it's not real holy [ __ ]
i was about to say look at my own dan
bilzerian that's the lesson from the
movie that we just did all right dude
when does that come out uh i don't know
we're gonna wait till this whole
ukrainian thing blows up oh yeah it's a
pretty pro
it's not it's not even like it's not
even it's not pro-rush at all
oh it's actually not at all oh all right
well then this might be the time it's
produced by putin it's uh putin's a
great produce
[Laughter]
look uh no i guess my arms look big in
that one picture there you go tank top
that's where my arms see if anything of
my arms were this big geez whoa that's
not real it's photoshopped yeah you
don't photoshop yourself and put your
make your dick big no i didn't know we
had that option let me who do i send
this to
oh that's a horrible idea to send a
picture of my dick to someone and go who
do i send this to and they're like i'll
send to us they won't get leaked i've
seen the dish you guys need to drink up
because i'm on this i'm finishing this
one and i feel
i feel great i feel perfect
tell me we're not are we we're not close
to done are we we're no no no no no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no okay good
good hanging dude yeah the movie that's
exciting
did you ever think you'd get to uh
because you were you know you were a
road dog for a while and then now
that's that's where we met 20 years i
remember you texting me years ago i'm
working with burke crusher and i went
who and
he's a drunk guy
no no not as funny
[Laughter]
you have photos of you guys shirtless
together i was like oh wow this looks
like fun yeah i was i am a i am a road
dog i'm a road dog to this day i i mean
i live on the road i like yeah i mean i
look i love having a family and i love
spending time with them and but for the
most part i mean my obsession and i'm
pretty clear about this i think any
podcast i do all i talk about is comedy
yeah i [ __ ] found the thing i love
and i love doing it and saying i love
writing it i love working with it i love
running being around people that that's
all they give a [ __ ] about like i don't
i'm with you i got a therapy one time
and she's like you need a hobby and i
was like oh it's i write jokes and she
was like that's your job and i was like
why edit videos and she goes that's your
job and i was like what what kind what
does she expect you to say i guess
regular people have hobby i guess
regular people like go well they have
hobbies to fill the hole of having
nothing going
on give me an example fishing
model airplane ship on a bottle fishing
is a big one that's a big one i guess uh
or are three rogan's a hobby guy he's a
hobby guy but he's not he's a different
hubby guy he's an obsessive compulsive
right right and he's got a ton of time
and a ton of money yeah so like i i took
up leather making leather leather yeah i
made a
i was like because i was i was like i
guess i have a hobby and she was like
you need something to turn your brain
off from work
so i went i bought a bunch of leather
and i made a fanny pack and then halfway
through making the fanny pack i was like
from tough to gay
i was like i was like i thought i could
sell these at my show oh now it's back
to work
and the second i did i feel the same way
i'm like oh maybe i'll be this guy maybe
i'll start doing this and then i'm like
this is cutting into joke writing time
remember joel is like learned the
mandolin i was like i will never do
anything like that that is not that's
not for me it didn't take by the way
yeah
but yeah
i think he's done with that no i i'm not
a hobby guy i'm uh
let's do stand up and i'll think about
stand up and i'll think about it all day
long golf's a big one too if i can play
golf like that's are you good at golf
yeah but it's because i'm
[Music]
surprisingly i'm a surprisingly
uh adept athlete like i can pick up
stuff pretty quick and i can get i can
make people very frustrated who have
like
like i remember we were doing go big
show and i said uh
when the guy was doing trick shot
archery and i said let me try one now
there's other things that i've also done
a lot of things in life like i've tried
i've done just about everything there is
to do in life you know
whether it's [ __ ] skydiving or riding
motorcycles or i've done a lot of things
and i've obviously shot bow and arrows
and so
snoop dogg was like
uh
he actually walked off the sex he was
like he's going to shoot us all with an
arrow well i was like i was like no
snoop i can do this and he was like you
can't do this and i was like i can do it
and there's anything from south central
rosario you have arrows i think are
different than both people hipster alec
baldwin
amish
and so here can you pull up see if burt
christ your bullseye
uh go big show comes up uh is that that
must be fun working with snoop i heard
he's awesome he's great i have a good
story
all right
is this it
no that's you're not gonna find it
bullseye huh you know it's not gonna you
know we're gonna find that that's what's
cool about bert though you love
activities like you go on the road with
them and you're you're throwing facebook
on the facebook
you're uh do you remember i
a great snoop story i want to turn into
a bit i'll tell you the bit you help me
punch it up all right
now we're cooking all right so
i don't know how much to
i don't know how much to
devolve give us the beats i'll give you
i'll give you the i'll tell you the
story and then i'll tell you the story
this is a fun thing to do i did this
with a comic one time who had to tell a
story and they didn't know how to tell a
story and i said well tell me your story
and then i'll tell it back to you
and uh
and so i'll tell you the story okay you
punch it up and then tell the story back
to me
or tell me the way you'd tell it okay
you're more of a storyteller than we are
by the way i know but you guys will find
jokes inside that story to tell so
you'll know the story once i tell you
the story i'll tell you the way i would
tell it right then you punch it up and
tell it back to me all right let's see
if that works because i did it for the
guy the guy was it was not i'm not going
to say too much because i don't want to
[ __ ] i don't want to wrap you know
yeah he did another thing but like he
told me a story he was like an hour long
i won't do that for you guys i'm
shorting it and then i told it back to
him in five minutes
and he was like [ __ ] that's a good story
and i recorded it all i said what's your
story you tell it and he was like okay
and he told it and it murdered yeah but
he punched it up for himself so
um
i i found out
my older daughter had part my oldest
daughter had partied uh she didn't drink
or whatever and it bummed me out it
really bummed me out and snoops advice i
found out i was with snoop dogg
but maybe not the person
you know the person you want to be with
when you find out and he said his advice
to me was don't be a [ __ ]
so he uh so
that night i'm going to my trailer and
snoop's going to his trailer and as i go
to get in my trailer he's like hey bert
you can see that i've been down he was
hey bert i said yeah he goes what are
you doing i said nothing he goes
come on over here let's take a shower
and i was like huh um and he goes into
saying come on in let's do a shower come
on and he goes in his trailer i'm like
there's no way i heard that right
like maybe it's in my head i go it's
gotta be hip-hop slang for something
yeah you know like we'll you know have
be some [ __ ] in there and we'll throw
money at them and it'll make me feel
better make it rain yes so uh so i go
over his two bodyguards were there and i
was like a boss man invited me over
for a shower and they're like yeah
i was like okay
and then he's inside and i was like all
right
so i walk inside uh and um and snoop's
in the middle of his trailer he's got
his hands a
big wingspan he's got his hands on the
counter and he's like all right
and i was like cool
and he goes so uh
church [ __ ] about the day long day
today right i was like yeah i was like
are we gonna do this he was like yeah
calm down calm down i said i've never
done this before and he's like are you
serious i said i'm being dead serious
i've never done this before
and he goes
i call [ __ ] and i go no snoop for
real i've you guys i did it in high
school like i did it in high school and
you had to do it he's like yeah we all
did it in high school i go by haven't
done it in a long i haven't done it
since then he was like i don't believe
you i said you've done this and he goes
yeah no all the time but like i'll do
with dre or eminem or someone
i'm like
okay
so i was like [ __ ] it i was like how do
we do we do it at the same time and he
was like
yeah you always do it at the same time
and i was like okay because i thought
maybe i'd start and then you come in and
then i'd leave and you know first
i'm fine [ __ ] it and so i start walking
back to the bathroom in his trailer and
he goes where the [ __ ] are you going
so i'm going back to the shower and he
goes why
i said you invited me over here to take
a shower with you and he looks at me
dead sober and he goes i invited you
here to take a shot with me oh
i was like oh
okay
i'll do that and he goes yeah
now i don't want to do a shot with you
he goes you came over here to shower
with me i was like yeah i'm a big fan
he's like hold on
hold on you thought i invited you for a
shower you came over and you were gonna
shower with me and i was like you
[ __ ] brought it up and then i was
like i was like how about that shot and
he's like nah man i don't want to do a
shot now i'll see you tomorrow so it's a
good story right yeah you're getting
good middle and good ending where are
the jokes and stuff yeah i think there's
something too maybe the next night he's
like he's like all right dude let's go
take a bath come on
[Laughter]
yeah there's something i mean uh
take a shot it would be great if i it
would be great if i had a great snoop
dogg impression yeah like if i was like
yeah
you know like or yeah or if i just go if
i was like so guys just so you're we're
very clear like this is where my brain
goes to punch it up i go i have a story
with snoop dogg i would love to do an
impression of snoop dogg i do a perfect
impression but people have said that's
racist so instead i'm gonna just it's
gonna be a little off and i was like so
stupid dog's like hello
would you like to take a shower uh john
dore is a similar bit to those rooms you
know what's funny is uh it's also it's
funny if you just like you're just
undressing while he's like getting the
booze right what's funny my shirt was
already off but i could i could take my
shirt off and he wouldn't say a thing in
the story yeah so i'm like all right
[ __ ] they take a shirt off he goes oh
there we go
that's the machine i'm like [ __ ] and
then he gets the booze down you're like
there we go yeah yeah
you want to do a shot and i was like
[ __ ] yeah we're going to take a shower
and he's like huh
i thought we were coming here to take a
shower and he was like should i just
hold the booze frozen all right yeah
that'll get me in the mood yeah
yeah okay yeah i guess yeah let's do a
shot too
see that's how [ __ ] that's that's the
best thing about being around comics you
can have a real story but then you take
it to them and they can just go just
move it around move it around right
shane torres gave me the best advice one
time i love [ __ ] i was telling i was
telling a story about uh about jumping
out of playing with rachel ray i think
and he goes i said i don't know this
part i feel like it's missing something
you jumped out of a plane with rachel
ray yeah
and he goes he goes yeah i know what
you're saying i was like what is it
missing and he goes i don't know maybe
some jokes
and i was like oh yeah you're right
because what i was doing is true and
this is what i do a lot you'll see it if
you watch if you're like a legit
stand-up fan you can see it very clearly
but what i'll do is i will say
um
in the story the guy's like we get to
the door and he's like all right we're
going in three so i have three
opportunities to make jokes but what
i'll do when i'm lazy is i'll go suck my
dick [ __ ] you yeah yeah i [ __ ] my bands
you know [ __ ] yeah whatever my three
go-to easy things are and shane was like
you should say you should have three
jokes
and so one of the jokes was
um
when we because we strapped into the we
you know tandem so we strapped back why
are you on why are you jumping out of a
plane with rachel ray i want to know
that uh it was for travel channel so i
did rachel ray's show and she was like
she on thing was like what's uh what's
like one of your big what's one thing
has there ever been something the travel
channel brought you to that you wouldn't
do and and i was a [ __ ] idiot i said
it i was like yeah jumping out of a
plane oh she was like
i know what we're doing wow and i was
like [ __ ] lady she was like i love
jumping out of planes we should do it
together and then you're like
you're like [ __ ] you're like i love
[ __ ]
rachel ray is so [ __ ] cool man really
she is really cool she is really [ __ ]
cool so we go up to upstate new york and
we go to jump out of a plane wow and so
she takes me
this is i'll tell you up to the shane
park cause it's it's interesting shane's
inside and this was i mean why i like
being around comics yeah is sometimes
the comic will see it very clearly and
you don't so we go to they give us our
dudes and we
and we strap up [ __ ] i've been told the
story in [ __ ] forever but we strap in
and i'm nervous and the guy's like
he's like are you nervous and i was like
yeah he's like what are you nervous
about like seriously and i go oh i don't
know that you'll get hard because he's
behind me you'll get hard you'll get
hard then i'll get hard you'll get it
we'll both get hard and our shoot won't
open and that's how i'll find us in the
in the forest just you [ __ ] me to
death in the ass little god man this guy
really loved [ __ ] he [ __ ] him into a
crater and so
so then when you get in the plane i'm
sitting in the dude's lap which is the
most emasculating way to jump out of a
plane just sitting in a dude's lap and
then we get up there's worse if he's
holding you like this
yeah he's kissing your earlobe i'm
shaking now he's really getting hard
and so we get up to the thing we get to
the window and i i'm [ __ ] this up
totally but we get to the thing and i
and
instinction i just hold on to the door
and he goes let go and i went no he's
like we're going in three my old thing
was suck my dick we're going in two [ __ ]
you okay
one and so shane's like there's
room for jokes and so i changed it right
before the special i went i grabbed my
thing there's like we're going in three
i was like wait i'm not hard yet he's
like we're going in too i was like are
you hard like and you just put right
real jokes in there yeah and then the
the truth is he said
oh my god what's wrong with your straps
and i looked down and that's how we got
my hands loose and we [ __ ] went whoa
and i thought i was [ __ ] dead holy
[ __ ] it's high up are you in the air uh
fifteen thousand feet oh my god what
does that feel like uh fascinating it is
it is a feeling i have never felt ever
ever since or before that
you are you are acutely aware that you
the dice have been rolled
that uh that if you look in life if you
are going to die
you can't change it like you really
can't change it
and you realize my shoot is either going
to open or it's not going to open either
way
i can't fix that
and for and that's why i would say
anyone who's afraid of jumping out of
planes they're the ones that appreciate
it the most interesting the [ __ ] dead
inside people are like yeah
put this on my instagram they're never
gonna appreciate it when you have a fear
of death jumping out of a plane
brings that to a fine point and you are
sitting there going looking at the earth
going mother [ __ ] and when that shoot
opens
i always said i always said i didn't put
this in the joke but i was like that's a
great time for product placement as that
shoot opens a brand should buy that
noise that
and then this is brought to you by diet
pepsi yeah because you will never forget
that moment that is the greatest feeling
wow in the world to know your life like
to and i started sobbing crying yeah and
then and then
i think i put in this a bit but i i
started crying so bad that the guys
landing is like hey man clean yourself
up you're going to think i did something
to you and i was like wiping it up and
then i literally had time for him to get
hard he's like sorry
this is what i'm into
have you jumped have you ever done it
god no i'm terrified so this could be a
patreon when i was when i was in sixth
grade i was uh i was walking down the
street to get on the bus and a woman
jumped out of a
a building that went splat right in
front of me so i'm like so i'm like i
don't like heights
well you've never told me this yeah hold
on how old are you
12. start this at the beginning i was
just walking to get on the bus where are
you
62nd and i i want to say like lex or
matt something madison maybe i would i
was i was residential yeah
and she
jumped to
she jumped to her death and uh it was
like it was it was like splat i didn't
take my metro card out i'm dead she
would have killed me if i stopped to get
my card oh splat so yeah i don't like
heights i didn't mean to make this such
a sobering night
holy [ __ ] these moments so i'm at
captain brian's right oh stop bragging
we're in sync captain bryce you ever
play you ever play there and stay at the
at the condo he had that was like near
like so he used to have a condo and it
was a walk to a starbucks by the way
people listening this is in naples
florida so you've heard me [ __ ] on this
before yeah big hell giggs in in the
america oh i used to love it and so uh
so i go one day and i i go
to starbucks
and it's i want to say it's around new
year's eve
but but i go to starbucks and i go in i
get my iced coffee and i remember taking
a piss
and as i walked out of starbucks my
glasses fogged over because it was cold
there and hot outside
and so i stop
and i take my glasses off and i go to
clean them and i hear
a huge
like a boom like like a transformer
exploded or lightning and i look around
and i'm like what the [ __ ] was that
and a
um
french guy is walking to go into the
starbucks he goes
you star are a very lucky man
and i said i know i thought he was
saying in relay i was like i know i'm
the luckiest guy in the world i'm doing
captain brian yeah
he killed it he walks past me
and i kind of watch him and as i turn
a
palm tree had collapsed behind me and
landed the the big palm front like a
[ __ ] 150-pound prom front had landed
on the ground behind me and hit the
ground behind me and almost hit me in
the head
and that that
near-death experience would go
[ __ ] man had i stopped yeah a second
earlier that metro card feeling crazy if
i hadn't got my metro card she would
have landed on me
yeah i remember i called a friend to
tell him it happened to me and he'd one
of those moms that like she just
couldn't stop talking if you called back
hey i was like hey is my friend there
and she and she was like
well he's not here right now but here's
what happened she talked for like 15
minutes jeez and then and then she's
like how was your day was like i just
saw someone die she's like oh all right
he'll be back later like that's it
that's it come on lady did you stick
around
i stuck for like uh
for like a minute i remember i had
another friend there with his mom and he
uh and she like kind of grabbed us away
and then uh someone ran over to her and
put a blanket on her so
she was still alive she wasn't
completely dead she's an old lady
what was the noises sound like it was
like you you're it's like you talk about
your brain protecting you it's kind of
like you you're like oh i've just
stumbled onto some like film set or
something this isn't right oh right so
it's like splat and then you're like
well this is a stunt person but then
you're like well of course that's not
what happened you know they would be
blocked off but i remember someone like
went over with a they found a blanket
somewhere and put it on her but she was
i mean she was dead she was gonna die
crazy old lady
old lady suicide yeah it's weird to go
that at that age you don't see a lot of
old suicide yeah maybe she's like i'm
done with life selfish way to do it yeah
right overdose or kill shoot yourself
now we gotta scoop your ass up well you
could have killed someone and that so
that's what i was thinking so really so
i didn't think about that that's a
crowded residential
street unless that's your that's your
your payback
you want them to know right
you guys pissed me off i hate you my
family ruined me
cleaned me up either she was skydiving
with rachel ray and she just went
splatter
i met a guy whose shoot didn't open one
time what he lived and he lived i went
to his house in wisconsin it had rained
the day before
and the ground was soft was really soft
wow and he bounced and he was like yeah
he goes i broke some bones and stuff but
i lived wow you see that documented the
bridge we've talked about this before
but
they said everyone who jumped and lived
regretted it the moment they let go of
the banister wow bam you heard the seth
macfarlane story he was supposed to be
on 9 11. i know yeah oh he did hear that
hitler oh yeah
yeah he got drunk the night before was
hung over missed his flight and he was
racing to the airport he's yelling at
the cabin you got to get me to the
airport and he missed it and then boom
yeah and then he said at the airport the
guy like it's like the most sobering
moment the guy hands him moscato it was
like it's on may yes saw what happened
and now we have ted when he gets to the
airport he gets to the airport but he's
at the airport bar he just missed the
flight and he ordered a scotch and the
guy was like of course it's on me you
know because because they knew that 911
had already happened yeah i mean if the
terrorists attack more we'd all drink
for free that's what i'm trying to say
wait have you had any
well you guys need to drink up come on
i'm on food oh you are yeah i'm on the
third wait do you have any in your life
five sets i love
near-death experiences
well i mean seth macfarlane man like
that's a that's a crazy one also of
course the the famous mark wahlberg
story where he he said he would have
stopped the terrorists and then he beat
up the asian kid
that was
that's what i'm saying it's like will
smith is going to be fine
came back from that she blinded an old
asian people on video you didn't see it
that's true yeah
damn you know i actually got accepted to
virginia tech the year that not
i've i i've had a lot of close calls
with life where i go
like
like oh that could have ended like just
an inch the other way and it could have
ended poorly yeah where you're like like
i remember one time when they
when the girls were babies with a
stroller and leanne
leaned down to get something out of the
stroller
and as she turned she stuck her head in
the street on wilshire and a car flew by
like inches from her edge
and her hair blew and she's like what
was that and i go it's a [ __ ] car and
i was like
i remember thinking
i remember i thought i think this a lot
and i wonder if this is a comics brain
or just a a broken anxiety brain as i go
well what if i had done like her head
exploded right there
what would i have
your life would be completely different
would i would i
what she said do i leave her there and
then get the girls home
do i keep the girls there with the dead
body like i think georgia at one time
she had a [ __ ] she broke her jaw broke
all her teeth out she's a baby
and they couldn't find her um george and
i just talked about this the other day
too what happened she fell she fell she
had crocs on she fell yeah no i was on
the road i was on the road i was on the
road
[Laughter]
georgia fell um broke her teeth leanne
called me
and told me i'm on the road with the
jamison comedy where i had to do my set
i had to get home billy gardell's best
advice best advice ever was that was he
on the tour with you he's on the tour
with me and he goes buddy there's two
ways you can do this the good way in the
bad way i know you're feeling a lot of
[ __ ]
you go to your room no drinks and you go
to bed
the other way you drink through the
night until you play your flight
if you're doing the second one i'll do
it with you
let's pick number two me and billy
stayed up all night we drank i cried i
was [ __ ] crying aggressively he's a
good dude he's the best he's the [ __ ]
person he's a killer too a monster and a
great actor an amazing actor yeah so we
go get on the plane go home uh
i'll tell you the whole story because i
feel like you haven't heard it and it's
pretty historical i've never heard it
and so we go home i uh
leanne says i need you to be a dad right
now so like
i understand you got a lot of feelings
but you got to take a xanax or something
to calm the [ __ ] down because this is
this is you need to be there for georgia
so i take a xanax and uh and then we
take her to the to the to the doctor
very expensive doctor in beverly hills
and
they let us know they're gonna have to
put her under that's what was making me
really upset is they had to put her
under and putting children under isn't
is kind of dangerous at times and so
they we bring her in at six in the
morning so we're before anyone they
bring us in before anyone
and we
take her in and they can't find a vein
in her arm
and so they like they're poking and
they're stabbing her now she's
hysterical she has no teeth her jaw's
broken she's in a ton of [ __ ] pain
they can't find the vein
and um
and they pull me aside and they say uh
we're gonna need to give her gas but
she's so hysterically crying right now
that uh we're afraid if we give her she
might breathe unevenly or she may hold
her breath and then breathe and that's
we can't have that we need her to
breathe um very calmly and so
it would be better if you came down and
you just kind of very gently
told her that it's okay and you put the
mask on her and i was like in my head i
remember my first thought was
if she dies do we bring the body home
like that was my first thought how old
is she
four okay three three or four
and so
she can talk she can talk oh boy and so
um and i knew her like that was the
other thing these are the weird thoughts
that i think i go does everyone think
this or just comics like i knew her like
i knew her pretty well yeah like i'd
known her for four years like you lost
someone you know i knew them four years
yeah but she was my kid so i go with the
mask i told her this we were joking we
went on a hike right before the day
before i left and i told her this joke
that i kept thinking was
i was like i said to her um so they gave
us some sweet gas that's gonna
it's gonna it's gonna relax you and it's
gonna be so you can't feel your teeth
anymore
and she said is it safe daddy and i said
it's very safe the joke i wrote was that
i was like watch and i said
[Laughter]
i said it's very safe it's gonna be
totally fine and i said listen watch and
then i i put it near my face i said it's
totally fine george are you gonna be
fine baby
here just smell it and she went in and
she went i said did you smell it she
because i can't smell anything i smell a
little moisture
and then i put it over her face and she
went to sleep and they're like
great job daddy
i mean immediately yeah and me that's
why i say if you don't know if you don't
want to have kids just don't you got to
really want them because you have
moments like this where your
vulnerability shows up you're like [ __ ]
did i just kill myself were you ever
nervous though were you ever like [ __ ]
i'm having kid i mean you have multiple
evenings i didn't think it through i
didn't think it through i was just like
yeah that's what you do that's what most
people do yeah so then this is the good
part of the story right yeah and so i
[ __ ] sobbing crying i go into the
bathroom i'm crying so hard i'm trying
to get my [ __ ] together
i then go into the lobby they've opened
up this dentist office now it's like 6
30 and the dentist office is open
and uh and in the waiting room it's like
a kid and his father
the kid sees me crying and his looks at
his dad like you said it wasn't going to
be that bad right there's a black woman
there with a big bigger black dude and
she's trying to calm me down because i'm
crying so aggressively she's trying to
call me that she's like like looking
trying to make eye contact with me but i
am just i'm doing i don't know if you've
ever cried where you just don't see
anything right
so 10 minutes goes by i've been crying
in front of these people for 10 minutes
that's a long time to cry
leanne's next to me she's crying
they come out and they're like your
daughter's okay she's awake and and
everyone applauds right and and so i go
back we receive her we take georgia sit
down in a little private receiving
removes a very expensive dentist in
beverly hills in a private receiving
room with a curtain and a leather couch
and uh
and i look at george his gauze all in
her mouth but they're like she's fine
she's still asleep but she's fine okay
so we're just gonna let her sleep here
and she'll wake up in a little bit but
she'll be fine and they're like you did
a great job and i was like thanks so we
closed curtain and i look at leanne and
i'm like
and the curtain opens it's the black
chick
she puts her hand on my shoulder and
goes it's tough being a daddy and i
immediately recognize her voice i turn
around it's whitney houston whoa
on my child's [ __ ] life she goes it's
talking to daddy isn't it and i went
leanne i i remember when she said that i
looked at leanne and the anne had george
and liam went
she sat down with leanne she was playing
with george's hair and she was like she
was a tough little girl today like just
and i mean i'm still crying leanne's
like like
oh my god and she sat with us for like
[ __ ] 10 minutes and talked to us
about being a parent and how hard it is
how the commitment is and and then uh
and then we hear uh miss houston we're
ready for you
we go back the anesthesiologist was
there she had she had gotten in the
reason we got the anesthesiologist is
because she was at the anesthesiologist
to do her teeth and then the guy's like
i remember this is i wish this was
funnier but he was like he was like so
whitney where's kevin costner these days
and she and i just heard her go put me
to sleep
so we go out to pay and they're like
miss houston's covered the
anesthesiologist bill
and we're like [ __ ] shut up we were
broke we had no money yeah like i was
like my god and then the best part of
this story as a comic
the day she dies segura calls me he's
the first person he goes whitney houston
died i went what he goes dude you can
say whatever you want in that story now
so that i told the story and i was like
she was like it's tough being a daddy oh
my god you broke chrysler and i was like
you know me she's like i'm a biggest fan
[Laughter]
me and bobby watch all of her bert
i remember i was i remember when she
died i was featuring at side splitters
in knoxville
brown tennessee passed away a great guy
and i remember i was
i was that night he's on stage when it
happens i'm watching the knicks lakers
game because jeremy lin had the 38 on
the lakers like the biggest game ever
i just remember this tweet someone
tweeted oh my god whitney houston's dead
that's linsane
holy holy [ __ ]
what if will smith had spanked chris
rock
i was just thinking that he should be
hired to slap babies when they come out
of the vagina
it's funny you were there you were in
knoxville i was driving to brea the very
improv
next month do you remember where you
were when princess diana died i do where
i was at my friend phil's house in new
orleans and we were watching snl and it
you know
uh emergency what year was that
it was 1997. i mean i was 11. no it was
1997. i graduated college i had moved to
new york to do stand-up uh and i was in
atlanta my girlfriend was a flight
attendant i was in atlanta at andy
sheftel's house and we were about to go
out and they're like princess diana died
damn and we were like shut the [ __ ] up
now
the funniest version of these type of
things like that's the funny part we
don't obviously i don't give a [ __ ]
about realness like i want the funniest
we were talking about losing our
virginities and we were saying on it we
were on cowhead's cruise and we were
like what song did you lose your
virginity to do what song
identifies that was like for me
the song i listened to after i lost my
virginity you get in the car and you're
like i did it yeah it was colors by iced
tea
am a nightmare and i was like i'll be
punishing [ __ ] or whatever my buddy
pete laurio says uh
i got the worst one
i was like really because you know
that's a nutella joke i lost my song
remember
i can still feel her beard that's the
best joke
it tells the king peeps like crazy like
she's taking her bracelet it was october
i was in the back of my mom's station
wagon we had just started when the song
changed on the radio to uh it was the
mash
it was the monster
[Music]
are you walking through the graveyard
mr smash
i love [ __ ] like that yeah i remember i
[ __ ] uh an older lady in new orleans
and on bourbon street after i lost
virginity i felt weird about it and i
remember looking at the tv and there's a
disneyland commercial on and the tv was
just in the dark glowing disneyland and
it was too much couldn't take it
it was too much old lady bourbon
y2k was happening
disneyland i thought about my parents my
childhood oh it's all over you're
command now you're a man yeah exactly oh
you're a man now like it's gone and this
disneyland commercial was just showing
me like oh [ __ ]
i can't smell the perfume colors
by uh
benetton is it is it colors no ah is it
benetton colors
perfume
pulling it up
is it
because i'm saying colors because
of i am a knight colors
colors by benetton that's so funny i
listened to colors
and the girl i lost my virginity to wore
this were bennett colors
that's so crazy was she black no oh that
would have been a perfect look at the
color yeah and yeah it'd be the trifecta
yes but i remember if i smell the color
the smell of colors
it takes me back to that night of just
horrific performance oh and it gives me
an anxiety attack immediately if i smell
colors by benetton i get an anxiety
attack scent is the biggest um
sense tied to memory really hell yeah
you can smell something like cinnamon
rolls and you're like my mom made those
when i was five brings you right back
the joke i wrote and i didn't say it out
loud but when we got in the uber i
wanted to go hey guys uh
if anyone didn't put on clone luckily he
put on enough for all of us did you
smell that [ __ ] car i couldn't know
it i was in the oh my god it was [ __ ]
so much cologne that's rough that is
that is like the you feel trapped do
they not smell themselves
i don't think so i think i think they
don't i think it's a a lot of them
they're working crazy hours so they just
don't they forget the shower and then
they try to it's like the french showers
they call it so they're dirty people
if you had to guess the dirtiest country
around
if you said what if i just said it
immediately
it was like albanians obviously not uh
no i would talk about albanians in my
new special oh jeez be careful really
they got you are they violent
they're the scariest really i think
they're the toughest people i mean oh
john belushi john belushi she's albanian
do a loop do a lipa yeah oh really yeah
it's not saying the knocky waste joke
but
we were in serbia and serbians and
albanians don't get along indeed there's
like oh my god oh my god wait this is
something something i think there's [ __ ]
in the street hold on one second india
is number one two three and four
it's a population thing that's what yeah
there's a billion though
top seven
it's
nine of the top ten and eleven and
eleven and then pakistan and then back
to india
wait what did you type in this can't be
the right thing oh props the camera
rooms are sneaking in there
okay oh my god oh my god man this
changes everything there's something
kind of scummy about cologne like i
don't know why but there's something
like i remember letterman
dig someone i forgot who it was because
you're the type of guy who wears too
much cologne i was like oh
there's something that's like man you
don't want to be that dude i i don't do
it no dimitri had that great joke i
don't know if it's great but he's like
uh you ever notice cologne rhymes with
alone
that's a fun little tag i can't meet you
doing these days he's on the road he's
[ __ ] hilarious he's funny he doesn't
get his dude
he does not he does not he's so [ __ ]
funny he was the guy that did stand up
we just stand up on the first night
together our first
yeah and he he was the
standout
guess who's going to be a star funniest
guy like his first set his jokes were
bananas brilliant stuff i mean his first
set i can remember a lot of his first
set um his first set included uh i'm
afraid of german shepherds not the dogs
just german men with sheep
i uh i tripped i felt fell down an up
escalator i fell for seven and a half
minutes yes these were all opening these
were his first time doing stages half
hour on comedy central was like one of
the ones that kept replaying yeah
classic that's right he is so [ __ ]
fine he's spoken to him since isn't that
crazy he has those jokes that make your
brain go like oh [ __ ] like he has a i
don't know the punch line but i remember
the setup was i feel bad because uh tree
houses you make the
the alive tree hold a dead tree and i'm
gonna be like who thinks of that [ __ ]
where do you come up with that his his
brain
is so was so different so like we were
friends for my first you know whatever
year of doing comedy and i would go to
his house and he the way his brain
operated he was like that's right today
i'm writing you know i have jokes and
then i'm writing 10 ideas for games i
have a friend that works over at hasbro
so i'm submitting games to him i wrote
10 algorithms or puns or
arithmetic word things like yeah he just
enjoyed the
he enjoys the the math of it the
calendar and all that [ __ ] he has the
world here's a record for the world's
largest palindrome there you go i mean
he should be in a museum he would do
like and he would have like an easel on
stage yeah it would be like a whole
thing but it wasn't annoying for
something like a lot of comics
i saw a guy with a leather jacket i
thought that guy is cool i saw a guy
with another vest i thought that guy's
not cool
so i figured out
that their sleeves are cool
a dalmatian walk by a cow and he must
think damn you let yourself go
clever [ __ ] he thought he was great too
i never saw that he went for the movie
actor he's a great actor he is i'm
saying was he's still a great one i
think i think i think i think it got
resold a bunch of times the movie became
moneyball but i think he was originally
supposed to do jonah hill's part joan
hills look i think
it's hard it's hard to sell me on any
one other jonas and jonah hill jonathan
is so [ __ ] good yeah and moneyball is
an amazing movie great movie here's the
thing with dimitri and this is like i
remember being jealous not jealous like
jealous jealous but like
he immediately was working yeah
immediately he had done stand up for
less than
a month and people like hey man can i
get you on my show and i remember being
like i guess i'm not good because like
that didn't happen to me and i was like
i don't know and i could not figure out
how to write a [ __ ] joke like i
remember i was like this is horrific but
like one of the jokes i wrote was uh
because i wanted to write like dimitri
because it was
it was like it was clear that that was a
joke and that you were good yeah you
could write like that and i was like
what do you think oh this is so oh here
we go baby what do you think papa
smurf's middle name is
i hope it's not boner
oh papa boner smurf all right i gotta
get out of here yeah
you just hear a gunshot in the next room
but i remember i could not write jokes
like joke jokes did you tell that to
whitney houston is that what that
part of a boner she's like i'm gonna
take a bath
uh i saw the i saw the uh sequel to
steel magnolias give magnolias back
dude i was so bad
i was so bad you got to start somewhere
but i remember writing how many bad
jokes you have to write to get to a good
one is like you know oh you have to
well i mean seinfeld says every joke is
a miracle and there's something to that
because jokes are so hard to write
because you have to
trick people's brain
so there's something to that about like
no that's not not all jokes are great
but a great joke is like
it's like a magic trick it makes you
happy yeah yeah and if if they were so
easy to make then it wouldn't make you
that happy exactly yes synapses have to
fire it's a whole thing going on it's
crazy that that that's i remember being
in uh
i remember being in um
scotland with patrice and
him breaking down comedy what were you
doing in scotland we were doing uh the
edinburgh festival that were there for a
whole month yeah it was there for a
month with patrice and rich ross whoa
what a crew yeah living in a house i've
been doing stand-up a year
he loved europe he loved going over
there he always said in europe i wasn't
a fat black guy i was just a fat guy
yeah why why'd you go so soon into
comedy
because i don't know to be honest with
you
because then you have to do an hour no
no no no all we had to do was like so it
was there was this guy named louis
shaffer who did
whose wife or wife why do i know that
name he used to run the boston comedy
club he used to be the host
he um
he put together a
um
a show of new york style comedy so it's
new york comedy in edinburgh so they
come in they see voss me
and patrice and i don't i really don't
know how i got picked to be honest with
you um i had a deal with will smith i
think maybe lewis was trying to make
like be like you know he's working over
at overbrook and so maybe that was with
it but even then you had to deal with
will smith had to deal with mill smith
six months into doing comedy what
yeah as much as i just pissed a moan
about how quick dimitri took off it
happened for me that way too but that
was back in the days when you could you
could get if you got a deal or a
commercial all of a sudden you were
[ __ ] like legit right geraldo pulled
me aside and he was like he was like hey
man people are gonna hate your guts um
because you gotta deal so quick he's
like don't tell him how much money it's
worth i was like i already told patrice
yeah and which was the petries guessed
it yeah and and he was like and uh and
he goes and introduce yourself to esty
tell her you have a deal in hollywood
she should know that and bert told me
the same thing he's like go over uh they
uh you need to tell sdn them that you
have a deal in hollywood they don't know
the comedy seller booker for people
listening right um i talked to manny and
este and so i i but i didn't i was
working the door boston but we went over
for a month and i remember watching
british comics and not getting it and
and it was like it was like they were
doing things that the words made sense
but it didn't make me laugh
like you know it didn't have the the
the pop that american comedy had yes and
patrice and i sat in a theater and
watched a very very very talented
comedian ed byrne
ed burns's name irish guy
and his big joke at the time was um
i was
shopping for mattresses
with my girlfriend
and the woman showed us one mattress and
i said well that could sleep three and
that's all me said
and the place goes [ __ ] nuts and
patrice and i are like
i don't get it
and then voss is like i think he's
saying that they could have another
invite another girl in the bedroom and
we're like
okay
and patrice and then patrice just
started breaking down
everything we go watch we watched uh
greg proops yeah do stand up and greg
proops was [ __ ] magical we sat in the
back and watched greg proops and but
patrice was like analytical about it
like he'd he'd pick it apart like kind
of like a chef going like that's
tarragon you know
[Laughter]
so and so
and i remember we watched russell peters
oh wow and patrice was like man and i
don't look i don't
memories are memories so i don't know
how accurate this is you know but i
remember patrice going this guy's gonna
make it yeah really and he goes he's got
the hustle man he's got the same [ __ ]
dane has
that same [ __ ] dane has he's got russell
peters was like a [ __ ] gangster man
we we saw um ali g the
yeah he dressed up in the outfit wow
[Music]
offended by he was like looked at it
like
the [ __ ] is this guy dude because he was
like hey bruv like you know
he was doing he was in the street he was
like they would go up there and bark by
the way that my memory is so [ __ ] bad
you've got to see if if ali g was that
see if you can find me in the trees in
boston because my memory is so bad that
i go you think there'll be a picture
online of this yeah of course
see if you can find
edinboro 1999.
oh boy pre-911 comedy yeah this is a
different time
that's crazy and ollie and uh what's his
name what's this real sasha bear and
cohen
was still getting started
wow i [ __ ] up my digital footprint
guys you're never gonna find anything by
the way that's a picture of me about to
get canceled the way with the [ __ ]
tomahawk spear in my arm
leaving 10 000 people in a in a [ __ ]
chant
huh
it was worth it uh put in patrice
o'neill but patrice is a comedy
just meticulous weirdo he was on tough
crowd once and he's like i used to say
n-word in a car and i changed it to
n-word and a buick and it would get a
laugh pontiac was it pontiac yeah oh
sorry remember that joke exactly either
way the k sound is always it's fun and
specific is funnier than car he he came
up so we were doing a rehearsal set to
we're going to tape it and send it to
edinburgh to see if we can get
accepted and i had all my jokes on a
little cheat sheet and i was looking at
him before my set and patrice just came
up and grabbed it and ripped it up and
he goes nope wow what and he goes you're
not that comic and i was like what do
you mean he's like you're the comic that
just says it just go up and say it you
know what i'm gonna say and if you can't
figure it out just talk
how cool is it that he did that in an
encouraging way like some guys would do
it in the way like they're hazing you
but he's doing that to encourage you let
me tell you all my patrice
encouragements oh please so that's one
another one i'm getting ready on stage i
still do this from time to time i say a
prayer and he says uh if i ever see you
praying that you don't eat a dick on
stage again i'm gonna slap you in the
[ __ ] face
so another one uh patrice we're leaving
embro i said
i'm really glad that we got to spend
this time together i feel like you know
it's nice to make a new friend and he
goes i'm not your friend
what he goes i'm not your friend but we
work together we work together we're two
days of work together that don't mind
each other we're not we're not
friends like don't say
i got friends and you got friends and
we're not that we're just two dudes that
we gotta work we got a job together and
we're like you know what i mean so i was
like i don't really yeah and then he
goes oh don't get feelings about this
don't get sad i'm just being real here's
let me ask you a question
i'm flying to tampa next week can your
mom pick me up at the airport i was like
no yeah
that's what friends friends do that was
interesting okay so then he does he
couldn't help but be so real he was he
he sat me through and listened he we
watched enter the dragon all we did one
day was watch on our days off we'd watch
bruce lee movies and he would play mob
deep and jay-z and explain the lyrics to
me
he's like bert this is some pimp [ __ ]
beep beep and i'm picking her up let her
play with the dick in the truck he's not
getting out of his car and he's letting
her know that on the ride there you can
play with my dick a little bit that's
pimp [ __ ] bert and i mean
and then and then so then i did i was
dating a girl that had uh uh uh
cerebral palsy
and she came over and she was aggressive
she was exhausting and she hated patrice
[ __ ] hate it a lot of people did
patrice hated her [ __ ] hated her the
first day they met she went out she had
her right arm was uh was
the thing cerebral palsy and she went
and stuck out her left hand and he goes
[ __ ] you ain't the queen give me the
other arm and he's like what's wrong
with that arm and she was like i mean
that's who it was
yeah yeah i heard some story where he
was there was a bunch of girls at the
comedy cellar and they were really
pretty like models and one of them had a
mole on her forehead and he just went
walked up didn't say hello just goes
what's that and touched it and he was
just they were like eating out of his
hand after like four minutes because he
found the insecurity and he honed in
he uh that girl stayed in uh in
edinburgh in my room she stayed in my
room for like four days and and patrice
hated her hated her so then cut to
patrice does his showtime special he
does a showtime special gary goldman
a guy named i saw that guy named
uh
who who uh steve brewer right what yeah
steve brewer he's jim's uh brother who's
actually provacs no he's no he was he
was like he was like a uh like a edgy
[ __ ] comic who had done warm-up and
his warm-up was so good they booked him
as the [ __ ] comic i don't know so i
don't know uh gary goldman
uh todd glass i think i know they all
did special showtime wow
obviously obviously i'm not a [ __ ] i was
i was early to the game on how brilliant
patrice was yeah and so i packed my
[ __ ] car full of people from
hollywood drove them out to brea the old
brea improv and we watched all their
specials now also i was very close with
gary but patrice is there so that night
we'll go to the very special the great
depression hbo streamed that man that's
it yeah that's a great goalman's a beast
he is a he's he's always been a beast
great writer and uh and we go we sit
down at the lobby of patrice's hotel
after the show
and patrice comes up sits at my table
i'm with like all my friends and he's
like what the [ __ ] are you doing out
here and i was like i'm here to support
you he was like what and i looked at him
i said we're friends
he started giggling so hard he goes i
guess we are
if i didn't go to his funeral
because i didn't feel like because i he
would have gone to mine i was like i'm
going to be real like i i found out he
died we were dropping off we were
picking up dog food and matt frost
called me and said hey man patrice
passed
and i started driving home with leanne i
didn't tell leanne and we were pulling
into our neighborhood and i started
crying and she goes
what's wrong and i said um i don't want
to tell you you're going to think i'm
foolish
she was like what and i was like um
i was like i feel silly crying because i
i i
he wouldn't cry about me
and she was like what's going on i said
patrice died and she went oh baby and i
was like oh [ __ ] and i cried in our
driveway and i was like he was just he
just meant a lot to me just you know he
just meant a lot to me sure and then she
was like are you gonna go to the funeral
and i said uh i don't know i want to
she goes would he go to yours and i said
no
and i said and i looked online i was
like oh tickets are like 700 bucks it's
like next weekend and i go produce would
be like you i wouldn't spend seven years
charging your cover to the funeral yeah
so i didn't go to the funeral i regret
it but i'm glad i didn't because who i
was at the time i was working on a
travel channel you know for a fact it
would have looked like like it's like
there's certain people that would come
to my funeral that you'd be like did you
know him right no i mean networking
that's the thing too is
but also you don't have to feel guilty
for crying for someone who wouldn't cry
for you like everyone is a different
patrice was a more he didn't seem like
that type of you're a more sensitive
person than he is right a lot lately
yeah oh dude was the last time you cried
a breakup how about you
uh
uh ooh i'll cry uh i'll start crying
um george so georgia um had uh before if
he was just like full house i watched a
full house episode
i cried watching uh
uh watching walking tall with the rock
oh that's a fun movie i cried hard as
[ __ ] sean william scott's great yeah
where has he been by the way that was
great i went i cried georgia had a
seniors uh it was a senior fashion show
and they did it with their dads it was
me and george and uh
and i
i was told very directly be 35 of who
you are
george was like 35 of bert that's what
we need today that's good advice yeah
and i was like okay and so because you
know you want to like [ __ ] sparkle
and shine and be fun i love the stage i
immediately want to do something [ __ ]
hilarious yeah so i
i i was forced then to do
nothing which is out of my comfort zone
but in doing nothing i got to appreciate
how beautiful my daughter is and how
this moment was more important and i
started crying and [ __ ] isla and
leanne are such bullies they the first
thing they said is like we saw you
crying yeah i was like yeah well i
didn't cry and they're like [ __ ] we
have pictures they took pictures and
it's she clears it to me like this on
stage having a kid makes you cry a lot
yeah
don't do it if you don't want one
all right all right [ __ ] it's fine i
have a kid but i don't want to cry last
time you cried do you know i cried on a
movie on a i mean on a plane watching a
movie movie it was uh life
eddie murphy eddie murphy yeah the
ending kind of gets here that's a good
movie eddie murphy and martin lawrence
yeah but the plane they say when your
altimeter is higher you you have more
emotions that's a good movie oh a great
movie i can cry on planes very easily
that's what i'm saying give that a go i
think that's a fact if you you you you
cry more in that altitude easy to make
me cry in a plane too all you have to do
is stand up and say we're hijacking this
plane i [ __ ] weep like a baby it's
crazy yeah or uh you're not in delta
comfort
middle seat will kill you
there's something also the fact that you
are flying in the tube at [ __ ] 700
miles an hour at 38 000 feet in the air
where you go life is precious right um
yeah i can cry on a plane easy as [ __ ]
i've cried a lot oh yeah certain
episodes of tv sometimes will just hit
you too like if you care about the
characters it's symbolizing some other
[ __ ] in your life where like i was
re-watching madman recently in the
episode where uh [ __ ] uh bert cooper
dies i was like [ __ ] it's so well done
it made me emotional maybe like tear up
a little bit i get i watched castaway
not too long ago and just wilson
floating away he's like well sir it's a
[ __ ] volleyball those are your dreams
it meant something else yes exactly uh
time traveler's wife
ah
when you when you talk about like it'll
represent the thing in your life it's
like it's like a
romantic movie isn't it johnny depp no
yeah and amy adams i'm thinking of the
astronaut's wife sorry and he um
he
time travel here's why i'm sitting
watching i'm catching i'm watching i'm
in and out i'm watching it i get the
time i get the idea of the movie but i'm
not watching the whole thing yeah rachel
mcadams i'm sorry oh yeah and then uh
and hey read the read the plot let me
see the plot of the time traveler's wife
they made a new one with will smith he
slaps a guy that goes back in time to
fix it they actually do did make a new
time traveler's life
and i reached out i was like um
chicago librarian henry d tamble suffers
from a rare genetic disorder that causes
them to drift uncontrollably back and
forth through time
on one of his sojourns he meets the love
is the love of his life rachel mcadams
then they marry but the race
relationship the problems and
complexities of any relationship are
multiplied by henry's inability to
remain in one time in one place i'm sure
she gives him a lot of [ __ ] about that
yeah hold on
say that again it's like a comic you're
always on the road i'm sitting on the
corner of a bed
you ready for this mark
how he stops himself from time traveling
is by drinking oh
this is too perfect
so i'm watching this going this is me he
shows up and she's like where have you
been
because he's goes back in time and his
history at times you know i
i can't tell you everything because you
wouldn't want to know everything
but but he's
i get emotional talking about it because
he's so [ __ ] good at the end of the
movie right
spoiler spoiler alert he dies right he
dies
but at the end the move you realize one
of the times when he says i can't tell
you everything
i can't tell you everything i don't want
you to know trust me
at the end of the movie he comes back
and you see where that one time in the
middle he had time traveled too
and he trium travels after he's dead
and he and his little girl's in the
front she's like
he's here oh my god i'm gonna get
emotional ah dude it's so [ __ ] good
because as a dad who time
tours on the road drinks and then you
i'm i mean i'm on the corner of a
[ __ ] bed you know i'm getting
emotional now yeah stopping
uncontrollably naked in a towel
she's like mommy he's here she comes
running out she goes where are you and
he goes i was just at uh garcia's
wedding what's going on what and then he
starts to disappear and she's like i
love you i love you he's like i love you
guys too oh my god
just telling about it
this is just me telling you
uncontrollably for 35 minutes
it feels so good to [ __ ] cry that's
heavy what if i was our job
huh
just crying no we get people to cry in a
room i think it's my girlfriend's job
what if you could just make a room full
of people cry
not in the not in the what if you could
make
what if you had a bit
that could make a room full of people
cry in a good way in a great crime yeah
that's not talented to be like you
stupid
i think michael's right michael richard
did that would be so [ __ ] awesome if
you get a room full of people to cry i
[ __ ] can't believe i just cried yeah
if you could get a room full of people
to cry
in like the best what you just told a
story like
when i was a little boy
and then all of a sudden they're just
like sobbing like yes yes for you that
would be cool as [ __ ] yeah you want to
laugh at the end we don't want to be the
the cry comedians you know the emotional
comics yeah that's what that's what
that's where hannah gatsby missed the
mark
cause she i mean you got i said this the
other night and i regret saying it cause
i'm sure it's gonna get taken out of
context and i told her on schultz's
podcast where taking it out of context
is an art form but but uh but i said you
know like hannah did kind of change the
game with comedy sure a lot of people
release serious specials now and it's
okay but it wasn't before her you know
and like i don't think anyone could have
brennan was before her that had some
serious moments what did he do
three mikes but it was still a
compliment
but it was serious parts of it no no no
no no no yeah yeah i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry i thought you were talking about
and i was like i was like wait what did
you do that made it
in my head i was like what serious
special did
you do because i don't
hilarious obviously i don't want to
start a war with someone who doesn't
mind who's a [ __ ]
kind of guy but you know but and by the
way just edit his name out of this
[Laughter]
but no but
she
neil did three mikes
needed three mics that was pretty
serious yeah
it was very funny too but it had serious
parts whoopi had a one-woman show in the
early 90s john leguizamo leguizamo
that's some heart in there okay we might
be drunk is brought to you by sheath
underwear whether you're worried about
having your dick stuck to your balls or
your balls stuck to your dick or your
leg stuck to your dick it's time to get
sheathed let me see are you wearing
you're not wearing it
is this not sheath
whoops oop
take it again this is sheath
[ __ ] there it is get some
sorry robert
sheath is great i i really like this
underwear oh i wear it consciously and
i'll tell you my girlfriend is like i
love that underwear and i'm like guess
what it's [ __ ] sheath so get some
hell yeah uh keeps your balls off your
leg two patches one for your dick one
for your balls nothing sticks the
patterns are solid
stretchy fabric yeah you don't feel
confined there's nothing worse than like
underwear where there's no uh
out for your dick
over the hump and you're like what am i
pissing over a [ __ ] brick yeah
that's so true sheath isn't just for men
there's lady drunks out there too we got
they got sports bras bikini briefs and
and uh boy shorts i gotta be honest i
don't know about this stuff for women
because i'm a guy i bet it's great
because the guy's stuff is killer oh
yeah uh
loving it mark tell them what to do
by the way my lady loves the the the
bras so go to sheath underwear dot com
and use code drunk to get 20 off your
first order plus sheath underwear 100
100 money back guarantee that sheath
underwear dot com promo code drunk get
sheath underwear and let them support
your balls baby
love your sheath
get on it support the show get 20 off
free shipping with the code drunk at
sheath underwear dot com thank you
all right we might be drunk is also
brought to you by diet smoke
edibles can hit you when you least
expect it and their dosage is uncertain
that's why we need the perfect medium
high we hit our friends at diet smoke
for their delicious delta 8 thc gummies
each gummi is infused with 10 milligrams
of delta 8 thc derived from american
grown hemp delta 8 is simply a slightly
less potent thc the diet smoke high is
somewhere between the chillness of cbd
and that classic stone feeling you get
with weed plus diet smoke comes in blue
raspberry or watermelon i literally take
this every night to sleep it's great i'm
not good on too much weed i'm a
lightweight this is the perfect amount
just lulls you you get that good eight
hours where you're out the whole night i
love it it's the perfect amount this is
a genius idea thank god somebody made
this because weed is too much thcs to i
mean uh cbd is too little this is right
there in the middle it's illegal in most
states and non-prescription just check
to see if they ship your state so when
cbd isn't enough and traditional thc is
too much enjoy the smooth buzz of diet
smoke go to dietsmoke.com
and use promo code drunk for 20 off your
order that's dietsmoke.com promo code
drunk for 20 off as a special offer
diet smokes coupon
can be used on every order diet smokes
delta eight thc gummies are not for use
or sale to people under the age of 21
please use responsibly diet smoke isn't
light it's just right this is a part of
the podcast where we just digress and
tell secrets
i don't think she gets
i don't think she gets i think because
the media wanted to wanted to
politicize what she did yeah i don't
think that was her intent i think she
did what she wanted to do and then the
media jumped on it and turned her into
something maybe she didn't want to be or
maybe she didn't want to be but it
forced so many people to [ __ ] dislike
her when i watched that special and i've
said i've always said this and i might
have stuttered as clear
but i
i didn't hate it as much i was
frustrated at it because it wasn't what
i can do you know like i can't get
serious i can't yeah
but it was like i mean so like maybe i
showed maybe i said negative things in
frustration because i can't i'm not
super serious but like uh
like i still one of my favorite jokes
was in that one of my favorite jokes you
know you have like a handful of jokes
you'd never forget yeah it's in that
special when i was growing up i knew
more facts about
uh unicorns than i did about lesbians
and everyone laughed and she goes
unicorns aren't real
there's no factoid like so i was like
that's a good [ __ ] joke right yeah
it's a good turn and now serious
specials are kind of like okay yeah so i
don't know yeah
i think what she did was is uh
commendable changing the game but i do
worry about these serious specials
because
i think if they're not done right
they're just
they're just lazy yeah nobody can't say
they're boring
i know beautifully i do think there's a
reason there's the reason we all do the
road so hard it's so that their the [ __ ]
is
punchy and that it you know
it's almost like some people do it like
they put in the work and other people do
it where they're just like why didn't do
the road here's just this is just it
yeah yeah yeah there's this weird
kind of
oh jesus couldn't die i gotta pee i'll
be right back all right well there's
this weird thing now where like if you
work really hard and write jokes and
have a killer special
you're like a piece of [ __ ] it almost
feels like do you find that it feels
like oh you're one of those guys like i
thought that's what you're supposed to
do
no yeah i i definitely feel that way i i
completely feel that way i wonder i'm
just trying to entertain the audience i
feel bad they're here i want to make
them laugh well no there's it's it's
it's no longer noble to just
just be a comic yes like you got to have
you got to have you got to have like a
political agenda behind it right like
like the fact that i don't talk about
politics then people go oh you're one of
those guys and you're like huh yeah
you're not willing to assume i remember
i i
i think what you're doing is harder
that's the problem it's like they're
going oh you're not doing this you're
not doing that you're like yeah but
you're only doing it because you can't
do this
yeah that's what i think well i think i
think if you sit there and work on an
act and you don't like
look man it's super i think it's kind of
easy
to take
a [ __ ] political angle these ways
because i don't mean this i don't mean
this out of disrespect to comics that do
that but i'm saying it's the reason i
don't do it is like i want both people
at my show yes like i want both sides of
the [ __ ] fence isn't that the
ultimate inclusive
you have both people yeah you know i
stopped talking about race entirely
really yeah yeah only because
um i felt like i felt like i was a tad
bit tone deaf when i did
like i felt like when i did it i was
sometimes
i was saying it from
simply from my perspective sure and i
was like
and and one of my like
and and not that not in a bad way i mean
maybe i talk about recently by the way
i'm such a hypocrite i probably talked
about racing this special i'm sure your
race jokes are good i mean race jokes
are good but so i mean i grew up in a
black neighborhood and we'd all say
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and i get black guys at
shows like you didn't talk about black
people enough yeah so i think we're
doing this doing this race stuff based
on how white people feel about it which
is actually the ultimate racism
i want both sides i want everyone at my
show
i don't want i don't have an interest in
like and like thank you very much i
don't have an interest in anyone
this is what this is where you could you
could slam me if you are one of those
comics i don't have an interest in
anyone leaving my show feeling
less than awesome i want them to feel
great i want the reason you buy it to
get to come see me is to feel awesome i
don't i'm not in the business of of
alienating 25 percent of the room to
really sell to 75 of the room that walk
the road we're entertainers yeah
remember when you're a young comic i
remember seeing a comic when i was like
19 and he walked half the room he was
like kind of burned a hole and i was
like that's punk rock when you get older
you're like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
that guy yeah he's ruining people's like
of course that's gonna happen by
accident but i'll never set out now to
ruin someone's night that's that's
craziness totally you want to kill you
want the room to be cheering you that's
great standing o yeah you want you want
everyone to have a good time but in
doing that sometimes i think the old
mentality was play to the play to the
top 10 of the room [ __ ] everyone else
well that's that's like the
you know whenever i see comics coming to
room i get nervous it's like that it's
that [ __ ] where like you know you see
the guy early on he's like killing in
the for the back of the room but he's
yeah and you're like well that's a great
open mic
right that's not a great comic exactly
you know that guy's gonna crush the mic
so i mean i saw sebastian not long ago
and it was the back of the room would
have made fun of him but
the garden loved him but you said you
loved it i did i'm just saying like i
could see open micros being like that
was bad that was hacky whatever but
he killed
the people came and got what they came
to see and i had a great time we're all
laughing it was great i saw him at the
forum and i saw him with my
friends uh he i mean just be clear he
comped like [ __ ] 12 tickets for me
good seats good seats that's nice and
had us gave us backstage access
and i saw him back there
and i was curious to like i wanted to
see how he did his hour especially in
the forum in like a big place like that
and he you know what was amazing about
him is that he did i would say
i would say probably i'm i know i could
be really office i'm not i'm not super
familiar with everything he's done i
would say
65 percent
new 45 or 35 old yeah meaning like he
did a big chunk of like the hits yeah
and i'll be honest with you
some of which i'd heard
i loved hearing them that way like i
love hearing them live yeah i love i
mean i tell the machine story every time
i'm on stage so i i get it but like i
didn't know you could do that much
because people do want to hear some of
the hits like look if i see ron white i
want to see ron white tell tater
salad of the best
well you have a machine ron's got tater
salad gavigan's got hot pockets like you
you kind of want to brian
you got to do some fan service too yeah
it's like it's like here's the deal it's
like no joke if i if i bring my wife to
see one of you guys
i might i don't mean this out of
disrespect to our art form but i kind of
want to see you
just murder yes like and and and because
a lot i think people think they're
bigger than they are before they are
that big so they go like i got to do all
new stuff well you're not bill burr and
you're not louis ck right right bill
burr has to do new hours all the [ __ ]
time because
bill burr has a huge fan base that is a
is
i mean
first of all big comedy fans and
obsessive comedy fans yeah and so and
they're not going to be happy if they
don't see a new hour yeah um i think
sometimes i feel like i would be bigger
if i did
more more old material oh really i feel
like i would be bigger if i just kind of
phoned it in a tad bit i think i'd be a
bigger comic i don't know i don't know i
think i think it's important that you do
a lot of news i think they come out i
mean i write a new hour every i like
once i do it i everything all that's
dead and then within a month i write a
new hour and then i take it on the road
or how do you do that do you just sit at
a computer and start
no i start banging [ __ ] out or what do
you do so i'm writing i'm writing
constantly so sometimes i'll write a bit
like uh
um like the snoop bit right like that
that's not going in this hour but maybe
it'll go in the next one so i always
have it in my back pocket i put it in a
i have a book where i keep everything
um and then i have
so the way i i mean i'm not to get too
inside baseball but i think if you
listen to this podcast you're into this
oh yeah i um
i have a i have a list of stories i'd
like to tell so like
and and i i know the ones i that i go
this is good this is good this is good
this is good
it just is uh
where they fall on the order line of
importance and then i have a list of
jokes like like legit jokes like shorter
jokes that i know that i can throw
inside stories that i write the jokes
and then as i do it i go oh that would
fit in that that could be great inside
here and so the more i can get that to
to line up yeah that's how i kind of
prioritize stories and then some stories
just like show up i got this great story
right now i'm telling
about that the one that i need help on
about um
going to an escape room and when i went
to the escape room with my family
what's funny is i rewrote it then it
really actually happened i rewrote it to
tell it on stage and it didn't work
and i went all right scrap it and we'll
put it in the list it's in the lip
that's in the queue but it's not it's
not working it's not working yet i'm
gonna have to work on it and then one
night georgia called me on stage
randomly georgia called and i thought
something was wrong so i answered
i said what are you doing she goes are
you on stage and i was like yeah and she
was like okay i'll call you later and i
was like i was like hold on and i said
something
trying to make something interactive
happen and she said have you told the
escape room story
i said no i haven't she goes did
you should try that one tonight and i
was like okay and she [ __ ] me she said
we went with na remember we went with
nana papa
zay ka no jose mom and isla and i and i
had already taken my parents out of it
because i just didn't think they were
part of the story i've taken leanne out
of it and the story the way i saw it was
like the three of us went to escape room
there was only people talking in the
story that's all i need to talk about so
the three of us go
and then i explained one part that i
knew could get to work but it just
fizzled out and then georgia on stage
was like yeah the reason
you got to tell them why we went and i
went i said i don't it was her birthday
she was like no the reason we went is
because we wanted to watch you and papa
melt down and i went
what and she goes oh dad do you remember
the crawl space and i was like wait hold
on and so all these things in the story
that i didn't think were interesting or
important georgia pointed out on stage
on the phone i then tried it the next
night and it didn't kill it's it's it's
killing in certain parts but it's not
great but then i go then all of a sudden
it gets moved up to the top yes and then
now i take something out that i've been
working on and i go you're out because
this is better yeah and so then that's
how i that's how it's like it's like a
it's like a baseball team some guy's not
pulling his weight in right field and
you're like well you're you're not the
right fielder anymore
i want to ask you about this on your
show the cabin which i watched i enjoyed
uh i mean the caitlyn jenner episode was
nuts that was completely no pun intended
but uh that was uh it was labia that was
uh that was crazy you just have caitlyn
jenner in there i love your tight with
your family i love that you're close
with your parents yeah and that you had
this like moment with your dad and
caitlyn jenner was that crazy so so
not by the way if you don't want to know
how things are really made you should
not listen right now oh
now we're talking so uh that day i
called my dad
i knew i knew katelyn you know general
was coming a lot of people don't
understand how the cabin was done i
obviously i knew those people were
showing up those days was that the guest
you were most psyched for no not at all
i didn't i didn't want her on the show
really yeah i didn't want her i thought
why not i just wanted comics oh i didn't
want any famous people i just want to go
i know but that's such an interesting
once in a lifetime type of guest
like i love bobby lee but you're close
with bobby lee aren't you kind of like
holy [ __ ] this is someone from not our
walk of life uh yeah but i but
i i just i didn't it didn't i didn't
it didn't register with me
how was the experience though so so that
morning i called my dad i'm in malibu
that's where we shot it are you guys
close you and your dad you're very
buddy you're talking about an american
[ __ ] hero right now
i was like
hold on miss gender it's pretty simple
you just stick with the one right i go
dad i go dad i'm fine he goes no no no
no you're going to insult her you're
going to call her you're going to call
because you're going to call her by the
wrong pronoun and you're going to ruin
your career your dad's smart and he goes
just stop just stop it's not worth it
it's not worth it and he goes and you're
talking to a goddamn american hero and i
go i go hold on what are you talking
about because buddy when you were born
uh caitlyn was running the the 440 the
the decathlon i watched the entire it
was in [ __ ] de gaulle or montreal
whatever my dad everything
rattles off things you just been born i
just quit track and field and and and
that woman
redefine my dad's doing the right gender
through the whole thing right which is
not what you'd expect out of a 74 year
old man from florida from florida yeah
so he goes
he goes just don't do it just don't do
it and i said well it's a little late
for that she's on her way over
what like what
what should i ask like you know this
stuff and he's like oh what do you mean
what should you ask i mean how do you
prepare for something like that what's
the training like i'm i'm curious would
you ask her did she use were were
fiberglass poles around then because i'm
always curious about that and then the
day before like when you and my dad had
all these questions so i go oh okay
that's a lot yeah so i go there right
nikki shows up first uh
yes i
uh fortunately been there earlier and we
tried to wax my ass and this stuff
and my this thing was stuck on your
dad's worried about uh caitlyn jenner
but not about you waxing your ass on tv
i had this pad stuck on my ass when
nicki showed up so i had this wax thing
stuck on my [ __ ] nikki's there and i
s and i and i say to nikki now i'm like
super hyper aware i say to nikki i don't
know if this made this show but i go um
i need i need your consent i'm going to
show you my [ __ ] right now it did
make it yeah i did it yeah yeah i need
your consent she goes i consent to your
[ __ ] and i said great so nikki rips
it off
and that's how we meet nicki i missed a
[ __ ] great moment of me
uh fortune and nicki all mashed into one
and then we break down we we stop and i
say um
she was so what are we doing and i was
like well uh caitlyn jenner is walking
over and nikki freezes
she goes i'm i'm leaving she didn't know
she didn't know what she was she was i'm
leaving and i said why she goes no no no
no no everyone's around we're in the
kitchen she goes so i did the roast of
caitlyn jenner
and we submit jokes and there were 20
jokes i wrote that did not get passed
and they said if any of these jokes are
told caitlyn will walk off the show wow
and i was like well you didn't tell him
bruce would have run but caitlyn walked
she goes the next day i went on howard
stern and i told all of them oh
and she goes i cannot knock knock knock
that's great radio though for nick
that's a smart move yeah
it's literally i can't be on this knock
knock knock on the door and they're like
caitlyn's here
mickey's frozen right dude it was so
[ __ ] good oh so we hang out we [ __ ]
around she knows nikki
um
she here's the one thing that i like i
mean i don't regret but whatever like i
had a list of jokes that my writers
wrote for me that were like jokes about
caitlyn
sex change jokes and one of the things
you think is like because they write a
joke in the show it's been vetted by the
network that is not real right and so i
i ran off a list of the most
offensive jokes that you've ever [ __ ]
seen and i mean it's like even the
things we did at times you're like what
so we do all the stuff we do the axe
storm we have uh we talk
and then my and then my
i i say to caitlin my dad is a big fan
and she's like oh cool and i was like do
you mind if i call him real quick i call
my dad
and my dad starts crying on the phone
he's like you are you are my hero
uh you're you're you have no idea what
you mean to me and it's like so [ __ ]
intense
and then and by the way the best the
best part of everything is
uh caitlyn
is caitlyn the whole time the second you
talk about those olympics she kind of
for lack of better terms bros out a
little bit oh yeah and just oh yeah yeah
yeah uh well so here's what we did so
and
i mean we have probably a [ __ ] 30
minutes of footage of her talk or her
talking to my dad
and going through like all of the
decathlon all of the training the
russian that was that that easter
yeah and so it was [ __ ] awesome so my
dad didn't even know he's on [ __ ]
camera he just talked wow yeah he just
talked and then moments and that was a
great moment
it was it was great but it was just
random i don't think anyone knew it was
going to happen damn i watched did you
see the netflix thing about bruce jenner
i haven't seen it oh it's incredible
it's uh you know the malice and the
palace yeah yeah it was the same same
series same series that series is so
[ __ ] good alice in the palace was
dope and they do one on bruce and it's
incredible i gotta watch it wait wait
wait wait what what did they do are you
[ __ ] they do they hold the cat like
all the footage of the olympics and him
training him freaking out in the locker
room it's incredible oh
yeah it's fun to see
crazy is that is that i don't know the
right way to say this but like
transgender
but what happened to the word
transvestite that was cross-dresser
my nanny was a transvestite growing up
and we just said transvestite was a nice
thing to say crossdresser was you know
whatever
so tran we'd say transvestite
crossdresser seems so acceptable yeah
yeah there's a cross drag queen yeah the
drag queen i dressed up as a woman one
day yeah i loved it i
loved it yeah
it was for a tv show for uh
and they had legit i had to do a drag
queen show and they had the legit makeup
artist come in and do my makeup and it
was what's crazy is i had some skin
problems at the time so i'm like uh what
was it called you know red marks and
stuff that alopecia no rosacea
eczema x-men eczema on my face and uh
and it went away after that the
the drag queen makeup artist was like
i'm gonna fix that for you
please and they put it you're never
gonna find any [ __ ] picture of me
i've ruined my digital footprint
everything's a promotion for a [ __ ]
tour date may 5th i'll be at uh i'll be
at the greek with mark norman cinco de
mayo
guys come on hey dude can you do you
guys do ads at the beginning of this
throw this at the beginning let him know
that we're going to be at the at the
greek may 5th where else red rocks red
rocks we haven't announced that but
we're announcing it now oh [ __ ] what are
we doing yeah yeah might as well [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it
uh oh tom's girl calling in guys
i'm doing a podcast with samuel and uh
and mark norman right now what's up
oh nothing i got your stem cells ready
for tuesday
dude oh [ __ ] yeah thank you thank you
thank you do you want a full blood panel
no
no will they test all your hormone
levels and everything oh [ __ ] tom
yeah let's do it let's do it no buddy i
do not want to know that my my i'm
having a rough weekend i'm gonna i don't
want my liver [ __ ] blood pan he's
four he's four uh cocktails in by the
way
of course he is it's [ __ ] fives
[Laughter]
well he even did the time exchange tom
we want you on on our pods
they've got a podcast called they might
be drunk you should come in and do it
while you're here
all right uh when
hey next week when are you here tommy
he's here tomorrow
come in tomorrow tomorrow he's no he's
doing it and i'm i'm in town the rest of
the week i'll be in
where what part of town are you guys
doing it in chelsea 40 40 38th 38th oh
yeah done done yeah just send me a
message we'll take a time all right i'll
send a message a four-way message to all
of us all right you're getting a blood
panel okay
he's got aids
all right
network now that's a that's a booking
yeah
look that is a booking it's hard to get
tom will do anything now tom's like how
can i get out of there
he's uh you're doing a guest you're
doing a guest bears oh yeah two bears
one cave check it out i can't wait april
6th are you going to be on yeah it's me
and you oh no tom no no talking right
i'm there it's me and you and then uh i
think me and ron white are the
uh he's retiring right here what
he says retiring from comedy he's porno
tarantino whoa
i'll believe it when i see it
he's gonna need it everybody says they
retire from comedy then
two weeks go by and they come back drunk
in public is one of the all-time great
oh yeah that's one of the greatest ron
white is
is uh i was saying this to mark at lunch
today if you told me i could have his
career at a young age i'd be like
[ __ ] throw me in the briar patch yeah
what a great career guy gets to go
around drinks smoke cigars tell jokes
and then i was like i think i'm on that
path like just drinking and then i was
like like you said that you could have
his career as a young man i feel like
you have i think i have it now
you're a young guy bert yeah he's sober
you're not he smokes a cigar and has the
tequila up there he did it i mean his
bit about cheating on his wife is one of
the funniest bits i've ever heard the
one about how he goes just the way he
says it goes my wife got this funny idea
that i cheated on in columbus and i i
didn't i'll tell you why just opening a
bit that way
the fact that you get a crowd of people
on your side
it's and it's one of the funniest
stories i've ever i mean i've said this
i've said this a bunch but dude
the
the way that he did tater salad right i
told you this story to tell you this
story yes it's been copied by so many
comics right because it's so
identifiable but it's so him and that's
why he's a brilliant storyteller is he
it's an old-school southern way of
telling a story right or sometimes he'll
rev it's like it's almost like a tom
sawyer asked like like
yeah yeah uh
i had an old dog who couldn't hunt he's
not what i would need to tell you about
what i need to tell you about
is my neighbor now my neighbor yeah
could never hold down a job every time
i'd walk home that's like the brilliance
of him like the misdirect of him
historians yeah oh dude he's uh he's a
classic i'll watch him with my mom like
the fact that my mom finds him funny
he's a uh he's like a classic i mean
that guy and he's charming which i feel
like a lot of comics don't have he has a
charm about him where you just like him
and a sophistication yeah he's swirling
around that scratch he's not just some
drunk he's like some upper crust drunk
like a seersucker suit you know i mean
he's terrific when i when i wrote when i
did that uh that we were talking about
this earlier yeah the best joke i ever
wrote is the [ __ ] starbucks joke
right i was so proud of that that was
the last special last special yeah i was
so proud of it because
um
because it was it was i talked to stan
hope
earlier and we were talking about knock
knock jokes and he was like i called him
up one day and i was like what are you
doing he said having a vodka grapefruit
and um we need him on here oh yeah yeah
he's like i'm having a vodka grapefruit
i'm writing uh some i'm writing funnies
and i went what so i'm just i don't know
i'm just [ __ ] around he's like i'm
not writing material i'm just writing
like knock knock jokes
he was like we're as funny as those guys
right i was like
i guess
he's like they're not funnier than us
we're the best guys doing it in our
generation we should be able to write
knock knock jokes
and i was like yeah you think about it
they're not
those are just good jokes but we should
do that and he was like all right anyway
what are you doing and so we just
bullshitted so then i was like i tried
to write a guy walks into a bar joke
and what happened to me and that was i
walked into a starbucks
and i and i had one interaction the very
very first simple interaction
and
and i mean
i mean this is the thing that makes my
dick hard about comedy
i had this simple interaction with that
guy one time right the next day i walked
in he's there again
and we have the same interaction a
little gigglier and we're like oh okay
whatever he's like i'll see you tomorrow
yeah so i go home that night and i'm
nervous i'm not thinking about the joke
at all at all i'm not thinking about the
joke this is this happened on uh i think
it was april 13th it was a friday
because i got her period that day
so ida calls me from school and says i
got my period i'm throwing myself a
period party i'm like what so i'm not
thinking about that i'm thinking about
this joke that she just told me i'm
thinking about that i'm thinking about
that as i go to gelson's to get all the
red stuff red velvet cake pasta sauce
pasta because we're throwing a period
party that night we're all dressing red
i go to that starbucks i walk in and as
i walk in the kid sees me starts
giggling starts hitting his friends like
it's happening and like i tell a
different when i tell the story yeah so
i go in and i and i'm like oh [ __ ] in my
head i'm like i gotta tell another how i
want my coffee joke i'll take it uh i
don't want to do it no no it's father at
all whatever the joke is the coffee is
black i'm ordering it black and i'm like
i want to be pulled over for no reason
at all i want it thugged out right and
the last one is i don't want it to know
his father because i really it's a third
time i gotta bring a banger kid falls
out laughing white woman says what did
you say to him
and i say the thing
and i
[ __ ] step i stepped out of starbucks
and i was shaking
i was like
it's like watching when remember when um
neo sees the algorithm of the matrix and
i go yes i go three times three three
times i walked in the bar guy walks into
a bar three come with someone else in
the bar ghost [ __ ] that's that's the
problem with cream that's the problem
with cream
[Music]
that's great and i was so fun and i was
like that's the best the best i can ever
do the best i can ever do i'll never get
better than this and then
then the [ __ ] nothing you know no one
ever mentioned the joke was always i'm
like
kind of cool after what happened
but you're like god damn it and then and
then i'm like going and i'm like i'm
throwing a period party [ __ ] i got two
jokes in one day i wrote half my special
in [ __ ] one day wow it was like the
greatest man but that that guy walks
into a bar i told him i told him i'll
tell you a joke to help me punch it up
you better yet you tell him
my my neil young joke
oh i might [ __ ] it up no no no no i only
heard it once [ __ ] it up and make it
okay so
you're at a bar
neil young walks in
and says no
neil young walks into a bar okay and
neil young walks into barcelona sees joe
rogan that's it i got it now neil young
walks into a bar sees joe rogan he goes
and joe goes look let's let's bury the
hatchet what are we doing here stop
fighting and neil young he says joe says
let me buy you a drink there you go
neil young says oh i've never been here
what's good and joe says well
i got i get a beer the shots are no good
get it
yeah
yeah because the vaccine yeah it's all
right i mean shots
shots um
yeah all right okay okay hold on hold on
let's start at the ground yeah okay
joe rogan yeah with the punchline is joe
rogan's at the bar and no one's getting
shots no shots i think that's the better
way what if it's kyrie irving walks in
well neil young walks into a bar goes
all right
how you doing joe joe goes hey what's
shaking let's bury the hatchet and he
goes let me buy you a drink what are you
having and neil goes let's do shots and
then joe says i don't do shots i don't
trust them yeah
i say i don't do shots i like i don't i
don't do shots as good i don't do shots
rogan's saying i don't trust him i think
is the is the the move i love the
[ __ ] math of how a joke oh yeah
figure out listen to like old school
jokes i mean gilbert godfrey's got this
great album of dirt have you heard that
album ever no oh it's incredible either
gilbert godfrey does a album of street
jokes and there's
he tells them in the funniest way i mean
they're classic jokes like jokes like uh
you know a man uh you know gets a genie
he goes
i want to solve all the violence in the
middle east it's been going on for so
long i want to solve the violence and he
goes oh i'm so sorry i can't do
something like that he goes okay let me
try another wish uh my wife has never
blown me in 40 years he goes let me see
that map again [ __ ] like that yeah yeah
classic like old and it's a whole album
of jokes like that wow just like you've
heard the the gorilla
which one grilling the lion i don't know
oh that's a clown he's the best it's the
best you've never heard this oh you're
gonna show this this is the best it's
the best
uh lion is uh in the jungle and sees a
little stream and goes down to have a
drink so as it bends over to take a
little drink of the water his tail goes
up in the air
gorilla comes out of the jungle and sees
the lion's [ __ ] and says you know
what
let me just go in real quick
and and get some of that so the gorilla
comes up a lot behind the line and gives
it gives them the old liberace real
quick
right
lion freaks out
gorilla hops off the lion and starts
running through the jungle lions taste
chasing the gorilla gorillas running
through gorilla runs upon a big camp
of people that aren't there so real
quick he looks around he throws on some
khakis puts on a hat and he grabs the
new york times and he sits in a chair
the lion runs into the camp and says hey
have you seen a gorilla come through
here gorilla lowers the paper it loads
it and goes you mean the one that [ __ ]
that line in the ass he's like it's
already in the paper
the brilliance of the joke and this is
this
is i forget it's a gilbert godfrey joke
i think oh is it i think so
brilliant look that up the brilliance of
the joke is that
you can't repeat words right so he gives
them the old liberace this bill burr
broke this down or how did someone break
it down to him gives him the old
liberace you can't say [ __ ] him in the
ass because [ __ ] him in the ass comes
up later right gives him the old
liberace
and he says and he picks up the new york
times you can't say papers twice he
picks up the new york times so he goes
it's already in the papers that's the
punch line yeah you need to hear the
punch lines are you mean the one that
[ __ ] that lion in the ass you need to
hear [ __ ] him in the ass for the first
time and it's already in the papers for
the first time yes and so it's those
little nuances of like i watched someone
special
and they kept saying the same [ __ ]
way i know and i'm like what the [ __ ]
are you doing well it's like the classic
carl and thing with stuff you either got
to say it once or 50 times
i love the classic street joke the one
about the two pedophiles looking at kids
in the park goes man that's one hot
seven-year-old he goes yeah it must have
been something in her day
that's a classic one too classic see
what bugs me is like somebody could hear
that and go you join my pedophilia
that's [ __ ] up blah blah and you're
like it's a joke it's all mechanics
jokes are mechanics it's all this
tweaking and twerking it's not about
pedophiles sure you know that's what
bugs me and i feel like those people
have sadder lives
because they can't see the joy in it you
know
chad daniel said that funny thing where
he does a joke about
i don't know whatever anal sex half the
crowd laughs half the crowd groans goes
oh and he goes i feel bad for you guys
because they hear that and feel joy you
get angry you just have a shittier life
and he just breaks it down you're like
that's true [ __ ] you well yeah i mean
gilbert's album is great for any comedy
lover because it's just like classic
jokes like every joke you love like you
know the one about the guy who's he
should face the bar he vomits all over
himself the bard he goes what do i do my
wife's going to kill me for being this
drunk
and he goes uh take a 10 bill stick in
your front pocket say another guy
vomited on you he gave you the money for
the dry cleaning so he goes home his
wife's like what the [ __ ] he goes some
other guy puked on me he put 10 bills in
my front pocket and she goes there's a
20 here he goes he also [ __ ] in my pants
[Applause]
those are classics those are like
gilbert's album great jokes i love them
now you see a comedian who bombs a lot
should hear that you know these
communities like talk about how they got
molested and all this [ __ ]
you got to hear that and go
i could never do that that's a hard joke
to write
the gorilla thing is a hard joke to
write but they're looking down on that
but i'm like you couldn't do it you
could never do it no other rules are
going to break them yes
exactly yeah i love i would i could
listen to
i could listen to probably an hour of
street jobs i know they're the best
jokes are so good i'm telling you dude
both you listen to gilbert's album
because you're going to be like oh these
are these are perfect do you think he
wrote them no he didn't write it they're
classic jokes that he's just kind of
telling because they're like these are
he doesn't play off that he wrote them
he's like these are old jokes yeah but
it's still [ __ ] great it's great what
was uh what's the one
um
they're hard to remember if you ever
hear the one
oh [ __ ]
uh you know who used to be great adam
was uh i met him buddy hacking i met
buddy hacker
i met buddy hacker i met buddy
twice i met him twice he was phenomenal
yeah
he his carson spots dude they're on
youtube
he goes oh yeah guy goes uh
guy goes into the doctor and he's got a
huge set of balls and he goes
doc have you heard this one
doc
i have a problem with my voice the
doctor says it's because your balls are
so big
and he goes what can we do about it he
goes well i can take him off you
uh and your voice will be normal but
you're not gonna have the balls anymore
and he goes anything to get rid of this
boys so the doctor cuts the guy's balls
off
a week later a guy comes back to the
doctor he's like okay doc
i gotta be honest with you i [ __ ] up i
think i want the balls back doctor's
like here's the problem
i put them on myself
anyway buddy hacking has great buddy
hackett would tell great jokes like that
and the long set up it's like it's a
different style of comedies on the couch
the setups take a while but right
do you ever think you ever think we
could i mean
is what we do easier than that
yeah yeah i think so probably but we do
it in a way that it's more entertaining
because if you just stood there and told
those it'd be funny but maybe for 20
minutes you have to be like all right
what are we doing here this is weird but
if you make it personal and make it an
event
that's a comedy show so i think what we
do is take jokes like that
and make them
work over an hour there's another one
this guy is uh his your wife was in a
horrible accident the doctor is telling
me a wife in a horrible accident you're
gonna have to help her uh get dressed
every day or accident so bad i mean
she's she's never gonna walk again he's
freaking out oh my god also she's gonna
have to [ __ ] in a bedpan you know she's
never gonna be able to take you're gonna
have to do that for her too and the
guy's like oh my god and the doctor goes
i'm just kidding she's dead
you [ __ ] it up i [ __ ] it i got good
news and i got bad news when he goes
what's the bad news he goes well your
wife's been in an accident she's like oh
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] what's the goodness i'm
kidding she's dead
that's funny when you we've had too many
of these yeah we are hammered what do
you guys have to do spots tonight yes i
got a fever where gotham in the cellar
stand in the cellar really i'm gonna do
bobby kelly's podcast at 8 30. oh okay
what about this jeffy heard this one
real quick uh the guy's eating a girl
out she's her vagina smells like like
hell so he goes in the fridge and puts
deodorant up here
[Laughter]
that was [ __ ] good i almost did a
spit take
that was good now what was the one what
was the one with the guy
goes in and he's putting corn in her
[ __ ]
type in corner
[ __ ]
mag we just see matt getting arrested
walking out of here
this used to be a part remember we
people would tell jokes all the time
like because you know we had no phones
we had no internet so people just sit
around be like oh you ever hear the one
about this no one does that anymore no
that was a big part of life well you
can't do
well do you think here's here's the real
question i hope do you think wait here's
the real question
i might be drunk
that's the pod
we
is there a camera on me
yeah dude there's a couple where is it
oh it's right there okay oh there you go
okay so
um
at the whole time i'm like are we
recording this
so so we just wanted to see when you did
batman when they had batman they had the
joker right
and then the riddler
is there a group of people who come up
with riddles and and doom in front of an
audience and then people solve them like
because they're a riddle guy like the
way we can write jokes the way the thing
we love about jokes is there someone
that does that with riddles
like riddles are [ __ ] great riddles
give me a riddle i don't know
no no no no like an old school riddle
like uh the new age one the wordler that
guy is that wordle i played i play
wordle every day did you play today i
play i play purdle the nba version of it
nba player oh okay oh for real for real
it's called purdle oh [ __ ] i play
we girdle wrap this up we're we're
pushing two hours zero right oh we're
over two hours so wait so we
like a riddle um yeah you got a crew out
there you have a you have a we should
make them a drink real quick so yes can
you make that
so you have a you have a a a pig
no a pig
this is jump the shark this episode no
no no no no no no trying to piece
together there is hang on hang on here
we go riddles funny no funny riddles no
those are funny riddles no i want a
riddle uh a a bag of grain
a fox
rip so i've been riddled with a bag of
grain if two trains leave cincinnati at
8am
okay go because 30 minutes later we're
doing asap's fables fox bag of grain
riddle right there
okay
okay okay
this is how bored people were back in
the day okay so i can't read it you have
a fox a chicken and a sack of grain you
gotta cross the river with only one of
them at a time
okay
if you
leave the fox with the chicken he'll eat
it if you leave the chicken with the
grain he'll eat it how do you get them
across safely um
okay i don't know the bandwidth for this
right now i don't know if i can hang
this by the way riddles are pretty
[ __ ] cool yeah like a good riddle
it's like word math yeah you're like
interesting it's true it's just funny to
hear riddles are [ __ ] cool you are
right it's a funny thing to say i don't
know yeah that's true
no
it's the bird of peace what is the bird
true love
well easy hippie
that's like what you say to a woman
who's chained to a bed yeah
so you take yeah you take
you take the chicken over first oh they
have the answer you take the chicken
over first
then you come back
you grab the fox
you take the fox over you pick up the
chicken bring the chicken back pick up
the grain take the grain over come back
pick up the chicken take the chicken
over like riddles i guess that's pretty
simple though no no that's pretty cool
there's the cause the chicken would eat
the grain take the chicken over that's
what i said take it everybody go back to
that right and leave the chicken yeah
yeah yeah i said the right i think you
said the fox second no
and so so uh so there was like the one
that one time this is like one of the
biggest fights i've ever been in my
[ __ ] life with my wife
ever been in my [ __ ] life with my
wife you're like do you bring the grain
of the chicken
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
out in pasadena i think it's in pasadena
and she we're in our truck and she hits
that you know that that pvc pipe that
they have that says
seven feet one inches she dings it i
mean hard as [ __ ] and i go hey uh
our our truck isn't gonna fit and yes
that's not what that means
i go that's actually exactly what that
means yeah there's no baby that just
lets you know
that
you it they just put that up and they go
just give me a heads up you got to be
around this height i said no the reason
it's pvc pipe is that if you hit it you
know you will get stuck somewhere in
here because that's not what that means
and she's still driving i'm like stop
[ __ ] driving yeah stop driving we're
going to
and we get stuck underneath the thing
wow yeah and and
i'm like
she's like how was i supposed to know
that was gonna happen
i said they put a [ __ ] pvc pipe out
to let you know that's gonna [ __ ]
happen yeah are you being serious and
then the riddle was how do you get your
car out super easy riddle
anyone
back it out
oh that'll that'll [ __ ] it up more is it
a convertible what kind of car is it it
was at the time it was a
navigator no no no no uh oh i gotta
deflate the tires
back it out yeah go to a gas station
reflect the tires nice little actually
minimal damage to the car really minimal
damage to the car i was it was uh
i'm
i'm clouded in the fight a little bit
because the fight was so aggressive my
daughters were in the car and it was so
aggressive when houston covered the car
though right yeah houston paid for the
[ __ ]
but you won the argument at least nope
come on to this day to this day
she goes that's not why those are up
geez
uh i'd say as you go
back when they used to hit women
[Laughter]
that's the only thing that's clipped
from this episode obviously that's a
joke
but like you know there's someone that
would hear that and go what the [ __ ]
yeah and you're like no it's a joke i
don't hit my wife i bought an oculus so
i could punch her winner
i gotta put a knife
those look [ __ ] awesome by the way
they're do you have one
bobby has one i believe yeah of course
bobby has one he's got every gadget yeah
bobby gets the bobby gets the the cheap
version of the gadget first the one
that's the knockout the one that the
first prototype where you're like it
doesn't really work that great and then
he gets the great one right bobby gets
every version of whatever technology is
from beta type prototype to the [ __ ]
alpha prototype bobby is so dialed into
[ __ ]
uh that [ __ ] i i don't know how the [ __ ]
i'm gonna do his podcast tonight i don't
know how you're gonna do it either dude
well we'll take a breather and we'll go
maybe i'll get a slice or something yeah
what do you guys what's your plan for
the night how does this work for you
guys do you have nothing in the cellar i
mean i'm staying out i'm out now you're
out should we head down and go find a
bar
oh
yeah
no
i'm just saying well
red rock summit uh
uh september 9th i don't know if we'd
announced that yet so if you're hearing
this it is a secret don't share with
anyone get your tickets
when i announce well [ __ ] we gotta do an
announce video mark oh we'll do that
um
i am in when does this drop today
now sunday okay
okay matt and matt can handle it matt
can handle it maybe sunday or next
sunday so then baltimore no i'm in
reading pennsylvania on the 7th
baltimore on the 8th
university park
nashville i'm in nashville i'm at uh
the grand old opry on the 21st and then
the rhyme and i have two shows on the
twenty seconds oh
great 22nd yeah
yeah that's a special one that's that's
a great room i was supposed to just do
uh to it the ryman and then and then for
some reason i got
i they are three at the ryman and then
they move one to the grand old opry and
now
i've got some tickets that's moving
people yeah yeah so it never [ __ ]
stops does it huh and then uh grand
junction amphitheater kingsbury hall
salt lake city um um and then i'll be
adding shows for the winter tour because
i'm getting ready for my special like i
said mark and i are at red rocks we have
not announced this yet hell yeah so if
you hear that don't share with anyone
it's going to be september 9th don't
tell that to anyone okay just get be get
ready it sold out last time it should
sell out again this time definitely and
then uh and then um and it's gonna be
[ __ ] and then the greek cinco de mayo
nice
that's a big one that's that's a
milestone for you um it's a big one but
it's a big one in like in like it's
crazy it's like
the [ __ ] chappelle's doing four shows
at the hollywood bowl
guffy guffy guffy guffy puffy puffy
fluffy daddy fluffy [ __ ] fluffy
fluffy is doing
two
sold out shows at dodger stadium wow
dude i mean pull up netflix is a joke
special
festival take a look at what take a look
at the week of comedy that's happening
in los angeles we'll be there too yeah
you got that right where are you guys
are you guys doing just small [ __ ] some
other stuff but
go back to the oh larry david go back to
the list
and then look allie wong
amy poehler tina fey amy schumer anthony
jeselnik aziz ansari bert christopher
[Music]
that's a slap in the face
will smith is open
john mulaney fluffy fortune jesus dude
this [ __ ] group of comics
that's a lot of money seinfeld larry
david margaret cho mark maron michelle
wolfe moshe casher mo hammer malia maria
valessa and senor marlon wayne's patton
oswalt pete davidson pete holmes the
plastic cup boys yeah no way they made
it in dude pete davidson down at the
bottom there
all right juan decides mark and i are
light editions too
this is so the i mean suffice to say
if you see a lot of promos for me about
the greek it's because there's a lot of
really good shows that week yeah i wanna
i want everyone to come out
for sure yeah and i'll be in la that
week and i uh we'll we'll do some fun
stuff mark we'll figure something out
out there i know everything's booked up
we'll we'll do something
uh yeah i'll be at uh salt lake city uh
why are you gonna come
[Music]
thursday i think i'm there it's [ __ ]
it better be binding buddy i'm coming
through uh just added la that's one
night quick night uh brea i'll be there
for the brave improv that weekend beacon
is sold out brother so
oh
[Applause]
shut the [ __ ] up one for the books i
might add a gotham weekend to throw in
there then we got nashville albany
uh toronto a bunch of [ __ ] coming up so
come through it's gonna be great uh
excited to be on on the road this is so
cool to see you guys chicago chicago
filming a special in june so check that
[ __ ] out the den beautiful venue oh i
hear that's great
i got a theater tour tickets are not
looking great so please help me out
folks uh chicago cleveland durham
dc uh denver
indianapolis two shows oh [ __ ] friday
yeah yeah who knows must be looking all
right then man that's that's pretty
impressive we were adding shows in some
cities and then some cities nothing's
moving so uh what cities aren't moving
cleveland
it's a tough one you know you got to do
you got to do rovers morning glory hey
hey you know the guy rover's morning
glory that will that show
that show will sell you the [ __ ] really
i don't even know this oh one of the
there are there are like a handful of
shows that you have to do when you go to
their markets you're a machine dude
you're the machine you're also a machine
and i'll tell you all the ones but let
me tell you when you go to cleveland
rovers morning glory will put you over
like your machine gun kelly coming home
for homecoming it is [ __ ] rov and
it's a great [ __ ] interview it's fun
as [ __ ] he's a there's a great the crew
it's a huge radio show huge and
syndicated they're out in buffalo
they're oh wow so it's worth i'll tell
you this and i'm i'm saying the you know
i love the inside baseball everything uh
if i'm doing cleveland i fly to
cleveland one day i do rovers morning
glory just on a tuesday while i'm on
tour on a tuesday on my flight home say
i'm coming home from [ __ ] la i'll
stop in cleveland spend the night do
radio get on a plane the next day wow
cowhead elliot in the morning preston
and steve um yeah i'm i'm gonna
steve are amazing there's a list but on
the list and i know i didn't name some
people there's a lot of people yeah that
are my [ __ ] good friends in radio
woody i'm there's like all my friends
yeah but and i don't know so i'm
stopping right there
because i i don't want to miss anybody
but like that off the top of my head
those are
uh go to dc you go to dc if you do
[ __ ] elliot in the morning
you might as well added wow
well preston and steve they just did a
thing for them on uh it's always sunny
in philadelphia they got a little camera
oh yeah yeah so it's pretty [ __ ] big
dude anytime that's my my go-to is any
time those radio shows hit you up
they're like hey man like cow head cow
i've known cowhead for uh
as long as he's been married for like 25
years yeah i've known cow for 25 years
celta yep
yeah my council is his name but uh
if
there are times that i i
i would do his cruise for free i'd fly
myself down
stay at my parents i'd do his cruise i'd
he'd pay for the cruise he'd pay for my
food on the cruise and then i fly myself
home and i'll tell you and i'll say that
it's paid off
it's it's it wasn't an investment in
anything other than i really love my cow
i love that guy but like those things
ultimately you see this weird payoff
down the line of your career where there
are people who've known you for 20 years
when you go in and do radio shows and
you become friends with the people and
you and you and you form a friendship
like elliott uh uh
rover
preston and steve cal
mike calta paul and young ron paul
castronova these are people like and
like i said i'm stopping so i'm leaving
people there are a few people that are
legit friends yeah and whenever they
said whatever radio show ever said hey
bert would you like to do our dot my
answer was [ __ ] yes and thank you
okay i did rover i did uh rover fest one
year he's like hey man
i'm not i don't know the logistics so if
i'm off i apologize for over but he was
like hey you know we can fly you up we
can put you up for the night and we
can't give you a lot of money i want to
say i did it for free but i don't know
but i don't none of the money never
mattered because he put me up in front
of like [ __ ] 30 000 of his fans and i
introduced machine gun no no i
introduced big boy from outcast i did
stand up before my stand-up bombed and
all epinope is perfect because i pivoted
and girls were just flashing since
outdoor venue and so we had a cameraman
who should have been filming me i go
spin it around i go let's see him ladies
and we spent 15 minutes just chips
flashing the mega jumbotrons and the
players [ __ ] loved it and then and
then you're telling jokes in between
yeah a million jokes you can come up
with then oh yeah and big boy from
outcast was like this guy's [ __ ]
funny as [ __ ] and i was like yeah i met
big boy daddy fatsax wow yeah so outcast
always so [ __ ] legendary so good
legends
you go to atlanta back in the day the
regular guys was like you'd sell out
everything you did the regular you did
good on radio i remember there are so
many andrew z was in uh
todd and tyler todd tyler in omaha to
this day you go do todd and tyler
and
you're clean really
dude i thought radio was dead no
it's not look
podcasting hasn't isn't everywhere so
you john boy and billy like there's so
many great radio shows that are out
there that have die-hard fans people
that grew up on it like not everyone is
a tech
uh
programmer you know right like there's
guys that dig [ __ ] holes that like
comedy there's guys that [ __ ]
put up drywall that love comedy yeah and
they get to work early john boy and
billy's on and they hear him then all of
a sudden they're like you know coming up
we got burke chrysler and they're like
oh [ __ ] now they're on a work site with
a bunch of people and they're like who
the [ __ ] that and it's like oh it's
the guy that shirtless guy rips the
shirt off tell god
mafia another guy's like i don't know
he's like hey man check him out you're
gonna like him those moments they they
help they help a career they're not you
can't it's not like larry the cable guy
back in the day when you just do todd
and tyler and they sell out [ __ ] or
bob and tom bob and tom bob and tom they
hated me they hated me so much i've done
it multiple times they always hated me
bob and tom bob and tom
is
i say this to anyone who thinks radio's
dead bob and tom legit moves the needle
still legit
moves the needle i mean um i think they
have to like you because i've done it
and it did not move the needle for me oh
no no no no it moves the needle you i'm
telling you man i i you know i i'm i'm
kind of a geek about this kind of yes he
knows
like
if i tell you there's
shows in new york
where i go that's worth your that's
worth your time to get to wake up early
to do whatever they say because they're
inner they're sharing their it's really
cool man i i never understood until
rogan but rogan shared
he shared his audience with me oh boy
the coolest [ __ ] thing in the world
that is nice think about joe and how
selfless he is yeah he's a generous guy
because he puts you over
and he's like he's like come on my show
right let's use mark as an example
mark's a perfect example because mark
was nervous to do rogan at first sure
and he was like i don't know and i
remember all of us were saying just be
yourself go in don't give a [ __ ] have
fun he's got a great sense of humor and
mark's rogan appearance was such a
[ __ ] spike
of people going who the [ __ ] is this guy
it's the rogan bump man you get the
rogan bump and all of a sudden all your
shows sell out immediately because
there's what is it 10 million people
that just heard you'd be awesome and joe
is generous he's [ __ ]
he loves stand up he's a great stand-up
but he celebrates you and
these radio shows do that now here's the
thing not all radio shows did that and
that's why radio gets a bad rap
there's a lot of radio shows we're like
i'm the star i'm the king
i have the deal i have the money i'm
[ __ ] you prove yourself yeah yes joe
never did that and a lot of these radio
shows i think kind of caught on and they
were just like yeah man come on in like
you do cowhead you know that you do all
morning oh
thursday friday let's do thursday friday
mike calta is his name i keep saying
[ __ ] it up ellie the same way elliott
uh hey come in my couch always helped me
in tampa show yeah
hey man we have courtney love coming in
and you're like for real like you wanna
smashing pumpkins opening because i can
crush this
you're one of the only people who did
radio when you didn't need to a lot of
people go oh i'm sold out i'm not going
to radio i still do really you do it i'm
doing podcasts
well podcast
is here
well i'm so this isn't radio i'm talking
about radio and success i did radio i
did radio in in new york
wow yeah i did radio of course i did
radio in new york i didn't radio in new
york when i didn't have shows in new
york wow because and and then and then
look you can find it
like i think a lot of comics wouldn't
find the purpose in it technically but i
tell you one thing i met dj mva and
charlemagne and i was like [ __ ] they
were in the same building i walked into
their studio i was like i'm a huge
[ __ ] fan yeah i love that show i love
breakfast club i love me too angela e
wasn't there but like i still do radio
it's dude it's it kind of
i don't know i it's it's can i tell you
i have anxiety when i fly i feel like if
i didn't have anxiety my blame would
crash it's the way i look at radio is i
go
the day i think i'm too big to do radio
is when the day my career is over the
the the day that like
people are like what happened to bert
dude preston and steve all reached out
to me and they're like
hey i know you're in philly
scouting your location for secret time
would you be interested in spending the
night and then doing our radio show with
uh rob
haney
[Music]
and we're gonna be at the parade and i
went
without a [ __ ] doubt was he cool
it was awesome i did conan with him once
and i was so bummed i didn't get to meet
him i just he was so [ __ ] awesome we
had cold beers we [ __ ] watched the
parade go down philly the eagles that
won the super bowl and it was like
[ __ ] awesome and that he's a legend
but they're not offering that to
everyone they're offering that to people
that are always cool they always show up
and they know come in prepared come in
with a with something to talk about
something to spin off on something with
the story their game a [ __ ] whatever
shirts off of [ __ ] uh uh m night
shyamalan i'm in i'm in a speedo there's
a picture of me and emily shanaland in a
speedo and i'm drunk as [ __ ] it was one
of the [ __ ] best interviews i ever
did because i'm obsessed with that guy
yeah right and i and then he he was like
he was like hey would you come to a
benefit for me and i was like
amna shyamalan said that yeah what
the truth is that he was dead yeah
there's just a picture
no that's uh whoa
wow look at that but yeah i see fat
people
we gotta
people are very loyal to you and and you
know your loyalty it works both ways so
it makes sense you know here here people
remember i'll tell you what i'm gonna uh
uh yeah that was your brother we love
you though you always been i love you
guys it's so you really you've always
been you've always been awesome and
you've always been hilarious yeah he's
always been generous too so we
appreciate it a lot of guys in this
business who get some fame and they get
weird and they get distant and they get
big timey you don't have an ounce of
that no well you know i mean you've got
a camera crew outside but other than
that
oh great all right well let's wrap it up
we'll have a drink and then we'll have
you
hey i'm gonna say this heartfelt cause
i'm drunk now
uh i've known you guys for a long time
and it's very cool to see you guys
[ __ ] blowing up wow it really is
really saying about you you're huge
and we and we take that we're happy as
hell we all know each other when we were
broke as [ __ ] yeah so it's cool to see
you guys [ __ ] succeeding on this
[ __ ] level thank you and by the way
if you enjoy this podcast
i just want you to know
you're
welcome
i created this podcast it's been a plug
for uh that's been a plug for you're
welcome everybody there you go see bert
see us take care comb your hair thanks
everybody comedy we did it sunday's
[Music]
and i get down in the same way
up on the roof like a cob coming and
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
way
we
might be
true
[Music]
you